Hey, why are you laughing?
That way I say swamp.
What?
What did I say?
Nothing.
I just said, you've been like dealing with this for years
now.
Why now do you laugh?
Why?
Nothing.
Hi guys.
Hey everybody.
First off, I just want you guys to know, we were selling
technical difficulties for at least 30 minutes.
Oh my god, we were so prepared.
Yeah, we were so prepared, guys.
It was just very unfortunate that the last five minutes that
we had, like, just something came up unexpectedly.
It was crazy.
It was so crazy.
Oh yeah, and it was on mince side, not on mine.
No, wait, wait, wait.
I plead mac and cheese.
Germany
Okay, look the reason why I didn't start start and mint
started before me was because Doka mean we had to connect to
a special server To be there and I forgot I was connected to
that special server So I was streaming over at Germany So
someone out there is watch was watching the starting stream
in Germany and being like where did this person come from?
It's like Grandpa Joe just trying to watch like Jeopardy and
he's like The worst part was the star screen was like not
even playing.
It was just that still image So he must be freaking out
right now and being like aliens or some shit Like Marta The
TV won't swap Wait, how do you say that in German?
When do you think I know German?
Well, you okay, you was mis-invited to a German convention
look i would say a european convention it is a is a
convention for all of eu europe is not just german mint wow
gotta open your mind it was in germany yeah yeah open your
mind and be more inclusive to the other countries in europe
okay name every country in europe all right
union who's not in the european union well then they're not
european and i'm joking guys that was a joke guys that was a
joke everybody wow and now she's lumping everyone in europe
under the european union european union no one can have
individuality here Oh, yeah, you name every country in
Europe then.
I already asked you.
Yeah, but you're like, oh, you're ragging me on about my
lack of European knowledge.
You think I know?
I don't know, then why are you ragging me?
I could have named random countries and you wouldn't know
because you don't know Europe, apparently.
Okay, name three countries and I'll tell you which one is
real.
We're going to play that.
All right, give me a sec.
Oh, no, she has a Google.
Give me a sec.
I also have Google.
You gotta Google.
That's not knowing the answer if you're Googling.
All right.
Oh, what are you Googling, huh?
What are you like, countries of the world?
I said nice things.
I googled nice things to send to my mom.
What do you guys?
Oh, so you're not even prioritizing the stream.
You're gonna...
I'm waiting on you, Doki.
You're the one holding us up.
Okay, all right, all right, fine, fine.
Okay, Faso.
Why are you laughing?
Wait, what?
Paso?
Yeah, Faso.
Malawi.
Eritrea.
Which one's the fake?
Which one?
What's the third one?
Eritrea.
I would like to phone a friend.
You don't know either!
They were all real!
They were all in Africa!
You said you're...
You said you know every country in the world.
So I gave you every country in the world.
I gave a specific, you don't know any African countries,
that's fucked up.
I know, I know some, I know Zanzibar, and...
I gave you three, and you couldn't even tell which one was
the real one, but they were all real.
He said, you said Europe!
Yeah, and they, you wait, wait, countries in the entire
world.
So it's like, entire world, huh?
Okay, entire world.
Oh my god.
This is, this is slander.
Anyway, should we play the game?
Okay.
I'm over playing Geogesser.
All right, we're playing Geogesser now.
You're right, I should select a South America country.
Oh, yeah, how many countries have you been to in South
America?
like zero how about you huh I think it's just a few minutes
of America yeah which one was it Argentina oh yeah
yeah but you don't dare for like one second does that really
count no I talked to the locals and they said Papa Frita is
so small
that's all you got from it what even was the fucking context
I was eating really small fries from McDonald's at the
airport so they were like making fun of you yeah they were
she was like I need to take a picture of this you need to
take a picture of you eating the small fries that's why I
turned up little bit guys i turned her up so you guys could
hear her better um it's not like she's giving us any good
input or anything but at least you hear them i'm gonna come
over i'm gonna send you to brazil we're gonna go to brazil
guys don't give me her coming to brazil
all right so apparently we found out that um we can actually
potentially kill people in in this game and like um and like
we if something if any of that actually happens wait so like
my characters die do i just stop playing the game i think
you just take over i think you just take over a different
character maybe okay maybe maybe i don't know we'll find out
i guess we'll see when you kill off your character also um
also there's quick time events by the way do you know that
basically like until dawn yeah and then my chat was like oh
min min and quick time events what's that supposed to mean i
don't know i don't know i wonder if i should play this with
a controller oh because i am oh you are yeah i feel like
this game is meant to be until dawn was meant to be played
on the roller you're right hold on okay i'm good isn't this
the creators of until dawn i'm pretty sure i think so yeah
so it's meant to play all right you guys ready new slot
ready oh i want me joe or charlie guys which one has a
higher chance of living
oh joe schmo joe schmoe charlie warly
Joey, he believes the heart of the card.
Okay, oh, you're right.
I'm going to be Joe.
I identify with Joey.
Just kidding, Joey's a wimp.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, Charlie.
I can't believe you're Charlie.
I'm Mint Phantom.
For now.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Wait.
to play with the controller press a okay okay that's cool
that'd be funny if we're like you can only play with one the
other has to do m and k oh my god that would be torture man
of madon madon madon what is it you don't know either it's
madon right okay to be fair everybody knows i pronounced
things wrong 99 of the time That's going to be you.
That's me.
Oh, wait.
In the box, they're dead.
I know.
That's it.
Ooh.
Elvis Presley.
I bet like, oh my god.
Are we coming back from the war?
I guess so.
What war is though?
There's a lot in America.
There's so many choices.
It doesn't give us a date.
Yeah.
But this is, you know this is based on on like a real ship
right wait it is wait does it space off real life yeah they
found a ship that like everybody died on oh and they
couldn't figure out why they all died don't keep bird as joe
the director called me up to act on this movie game that's
you charlie well i'm wasted yeah you're no subtitles oh yeah
you turn it on yourself i turn mine on guys i have subtitles
wait how do i turn it on i guess we'll find you'll have to
find out after this scene okay whisp i have subtitles
look at it she's hot oh my god he's fighting that thing oh
take his ass oh wait this is me oh my god what are you gonna
do r to aim rt to punch punch the thing use r to choose can
i like move it for you oh i can you can yeah can you not
move it wait i am moving it no you're not i'm moving it no
i'm moving it i'm moving it totally me no you're not okay i
want to know will i be rich oh my god be I pick?
Oh, my God.
How do I pick?
I'm killing it.
What are you doing?
I'm doing QTEs.
I'm QTEs.
Oh, we're doing different things.
Wait, why can't I pick?
Oh, why'd you buy the game?
Yeah, don't you have to wait.
Yeah, you go do your some, go do your fucking settings.
Yeah, hold on.
I'm doing my subtitles.
Oh, you're actually doing it?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing my subtitles.
Okay, we're good.
Continue.
I'm ready.
Four.
Three.
Two.
Wait, you're fighting?
Yes, I'm fighting.
Wait, I can't press anything.
Wait.
You should have picked Charlie.
Wait, I didn't turn you up anyway.
This gives me a chance to turn you up anyway.
Oh, my God.
How do I pick?
I'm pressing B.
Yeah, it's my QTE.
what's our what's it's not letting me pick I swear pressing
everything yeah because I'm the one who's playing no I have
my own screen I don't know what's going on in your side it's
not letting me pick I'm pressing everything you suck at the
game i already said nothing hey oh you're already done okay
hey guys i didn't say anything were you playing like a game
of cards i was trying to do the dialogue section if i
couldn't pick a dialogue i was gaming and you were dying to
some old man who's asleep
oh wait now i have to do the thing you just did oh you were
doing this Um...
Um...
Were you able to pick a sectile on?
You were doing yes!
Are you freaking out?
I picked it.
What did you press?
You just move with R.
Yeah, but how did you select it?
Um...
Ooh, I'm gonna use the rooster tile.
Do you just...
You just hover over it?
That's all you did?
That's literally it?
Yes, you're wrong too.
It wasn't just it wasn't just press R you just hover You
just hover oh wait Pick it up.
Oh my god.
I don't know anything about my son What about my son?
I don't think you'll never know.
I'll never know I'll never know about my son or if I'll ever
be rich I never know.
I just did nothing.
I feel like it's hard to balance the audio in this.
He's told me, like, blood.
Oh, are you done?
Yeah, I'm done.
You don't need to know anything more about your future.
If I don't know my future, you don't know your future.
Did you beat the dummy?
Yeah, I beat the dummy.
I did it faster than you.
Did you get hit?
No.
Did you get hit on the quickie?
time events?
I don't believe you.
Did you get hit on the...
No, I did not!
Did you get hit on the quick time events?
If anybody's dying, it's on your side.
No, I got an achievement for it.
I got an achievement.
I think all of us get an achievement for finishing it.
Oh, shit, the death box.
That's gonna be you.
I mean, judging by the quick time events, stuff, I think
it's you.
Don't write death POV.
I might not make right dial don't see you we got our
strengths I'm the quick time event person and you're the
dialogue person why are there three boxes wait why who's a
third person uh-oh let's chat wait one of our chats survives
oh who's that guy
where's my 50 cents yeah i was like what 50 cents meant you
don't need 50 cents you stole my 50 whoa that's the third
guy no that was you you just got punched audio
is like why is it so loud yeah i know why is this sound
effect so loud why are you dead already come on like what
did i do you're the drunk one like hold it
50 cents and then I got punched.
Like...
Guys, it's not the game voice that's low.
It's the...
It's everything else is high.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that, yeah.
I keep trying to like adjust it, but it's like all over the
place.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there's the ship!
Whoa!
Oh no.
What the fuck?
Titanic moment.
It struck...
Oh.
Ew!
What is that?
There's some goo.
The death is leaking into the water.
Oh no.
Frankenstein.
The new pandemic.
You guys know that Frankenstein, the reason his arms are
stuck out is because he was supposed to be blind and they
just wrote that out of the story but kept his arms sticking
out.
It's kind of messed up.
It's Frankenstein's monster.
Whatever.
If you're going to give a fact about Frankenstein, use the
correct terminology.
Frankenstein's on my side.
What the fuck?
Whoa.
What's going on?
Oh, I'm in the bridge.
It's Charlie.
There's you.
Where does Joe?
Oh, wait.
That's me.
Yeah, you're looking at yourself.
Oh, yeah.
I'm looking at myself.
Wait, where are you?
I'm at the sickbay.
Okay, I paused it because I need it because I didn't just
the audio the audio is fucked up You're right.
Okay, I'm putting the sound effects and the music down.
We do not need such high sound effects No, I'm gonna put it
like 670.
I'm gonna put it at 72.
Yeah, see You're welcome That's an audio preset.
I have an idea.
I just put all right All right, I turned down music and the
sound effects.
Are you ready?
Hold on.
All right, fine.
You can put...
You press continue then.
I'm pressing continue.
Never mind.
No.
I press continue.
Yeah.
I waited too long.
So now I'm adjusting again.
Okay.
Now you can press continue.
I already did.
All right.
There we go.
Three.
Two.
One.
I guess people can use like the settings thing to fuck each
other over.
Whoa, there's blood on the wall.
Wait, there's blood.
Oh, wait, I got the med kit.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Okay, it's not my blood.
Oh, call an ambulance, but not for me.
Okay, I know where the blood came from.
I know where the blood came from.
I need to move me in my chat.
There's text that's on the right side.
Okay, I know where the blood came from.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
I'm moving us over.
come over here chat that's not a man chat come here oh you
guys are like censored to oh god you guys don't worry about
it okay sorry five four three two one there's so there's a
dead body on my side um there's just blood on the wall here
let's see oh i'm looking at the key whoa whoa What a key.
I have a key.
I'm just looking at blood.
Who is this?
Come get me out of here then, maybe.
Maybe that's for me to get out.
I need to see.
Wait, it's a doctor.
Is he dead?
Yes, I'm pretty sure he was stuffed in the locker.
I'm pretty sure he's dead.
Private Charles Anderson.
What happened?
Wait, what happened while I was sleeping?
Oh, we were both sleeping.
10 days approved.
Oh, that's me.
Yeah, what the heck happened?
To Pops, come back soon.
I'm pretty sure we weren't sleeping for that long Yeah Yeah,
I'm opening up Code I'm opening up a lock I'm coming out I'm
coming out of the ship Out of the ship Where are you?
I'm on me I'm outside the ship now Okay, I don't like how
you don't know What's going on I'm stuck in the brig Oh my
gosh, this is tank Oh, it's Resident Evil I'm stuck in the
brig The brig Something's gonna pop out Oh, wait, is that
you?
Are you in this side?
Well, yeah, that's me.
That's you, Charlie.
Just get me out of here already.
Oh, you were in detention for punching me.
You were in detention.
I didn't punch you.
Oh, yeah.
Why were you locked inside?
I don't know.
What are you looking at?
Hey there.
What is happening?
Find out what's happening on this?
Oh, where are we going to go?
whoa where are we gonna go i'm gonna go charlie Charlie what
are we gonna go charlie i don't know i don't know i don't
know i'm stuck in the wall it's okay i'll go charlie i'll
put my own way oh what's that i don't know run oh god
That's gonna be you.
Who's that?
Press A in time with a heartbeat?
Okay, if you don't get this right, I swear to God.
We fucked up!
You fucked up!
God!
You fucked me!
Leg, we were fine!
We were fine!
Leg, leg, leg, leg!
Where do we go?
Where do we go, where do we go?
sanai joe, come here, joe.
Where did we go from?
Sanai joe.
Oh, wait.
This is where we came from.
I like how like we just were like, oh, oh, oh.
We're like two bumbling guys.
Charlie and Joe.
The adventures of Charlie and Joe.
What is it?
Yeah.
How did you mess up that?
You just press A.
I don't know.
I want to see what would happen if he can.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you wanted to see what it had.
He didn't shoot us.
It's fine.
He was safe.
Okay.
What the hell?
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to put settings up right now, okay?
Get ready.
I need to turn you up again.
I need...
Okay.
Settings time.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I need...
Yeah, I need...
Okay, we both needed to fix it, so that's fine.
Okay.
I'll turn in my sound effect.
60.
Why is the sound effects so loud?
I don't know.
Actually, I'm going to turn mine down a little bit, too.
Yeah.
Okay, and then I'm turning you up a little bit, and I'm
turning the overall game a little bit.
60.
Alright.
This should work.
Is this a way out or whatever that game is?
Well, it feels like it.
It's like the horror version of a way out.
Sorry, chat.
off a little bit sorry let me all right here i'm ready are
you ready yeah all right i already clicked ready okay i
don't know that i can't see all right five four three two
one okay here we go we're walking down the hall we're fine
where did you go oh there you are didn't we come here who's
that who was that what was that joe did you not see it i'm
charlie you're i mean Do you not see Charlie?
Do you not see a guy running in front of us?
No, there was no guy.
Wait.
Oh no, what's going on?
What are you talking about?
Charlie, I think I'm still drunk.
Joe, take your meds.
I quoted the doctor's dead!
There's a door flashing over there.
Yeah, yeah, over here, over here.
Why are our feet smelly?
Ew.
Wait, do you not see it?
There's like a flashing over here.
Get it.
I'm getting it.
Come on, Joe.
yeah help me i literally just came back from the sick bay
why is my face just so all right oh hey okay i'm pressing
i'm pressing i'm pressing it oh yeah he's dead yeah you said
it foobar and then son what the fuck foobar and then some
what does that even what does that mean oh my god oh that's
a lot of blood are we getting invaded what's happening what
happened on the ship stays on the ship oh okay i'm first i
guess yeah even though i open the door yeah our feet are
really wait why is there like gas on the floor that's what
i'm saying we're smelling dead another step who's the lucky
winner who is it checking him out i'm trying to check him
out yeah what do you see i'm stuck i'm stuck i get oh there
it is oh my god what's going on what's going on he looks
like he looks like peter griffin Oh
My god, it's him Well, he's not one Wait, what's wrong with
his eyes?
He's like looking he's like blank eyes.
Yeah Oh, what's going on guys?
Oh, there's nothing this way.
I feel like it was like Like the frat boys be like hey guys,
what's good?
What do we do?
Wow, look at these camera angles so cinematic.
Oh, did you went through that door?
I can't see anything.
Where are you?
I'm heading downstairs.
Oh my god.
It is so cinematic.
I can't see where I'm going.
Oh, Fubar is a military sniper fucked unbelievably beyond
all recognition.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
To walk faster.
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
Alright, now we can, can we run?
Like.
I don't feel like I'm walking very much.
Me too.
I feel like I don't think I'm walking that fast.
Not gonna lie.
Neither are we maybe we're not pressing the right button.
It's LB.
Wait There's the one Which one's me Oh, this is me.
Whoa.
Oh, you don't see that?
Hey, Joe.
No, I didn't say anything.
You see that kid over there?
Oh, it's only me It was a child Joe, what's wrong with you?
Of course you doki would be the one The crazy one So you're
walking in circles.
You're just like, I don't know.
I don't know, Charlie.
I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good, Charlie.
I'm seeing children.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Cow, cow, cow.
Uh-oh.
I have a gun.
Is that a good idea?
Wait.
Oh, why did I have a gun?
What the hell?
Why can't I ever have a gun?
why this is accurate this is very accurate you were meant to
have the katana i was meant to have the katana was that meme
the guy you were having hallucinations i don't think you
should be holding anything
is that you that's me i saw another i saw another child did
you i saw a child again yeah what the do you see on your
screen oh the dead people are actually talking to me right
now oh okay so at least we're not all we're both crazy then
oh what what just happened oh god no it's you talking to me
wait what yeah you're you're you're looking at me but you're
dead uh i'm gonna investigate wait how do i investigate How
are you investigating?
I'm still hallucinating.
I'm investigating your body.
Oh, there's a man here.
Wait, there's me.
No, I think you're the man.
Wait, what?
No, child!
I see the child has your knife.
You gave the child a knife!
No, I still have it.
I still have it.
Oh.
I shot the child!
Oh, my God.
The zombie, you missed?
miss are you shooting me I don't know but I missed
apparently wait did I die from that I think I'm dead too
force on me and killed me I tried it I missed the child and
then I died from a heart attack
I just died for a cringe because you were so bad you died of
cringe real
Who is he that's not Charlie or Joe?
Give us your location to do it Do it man.
You're our only hope Random sailor Uh-oh, uh-oh Wait, what?
What the hell?
He has four arms Doki, I think something weird's going on
here.
Yeah, I don't think that...
I think that ship might be haunted.
He's got his little baby cross.
God cannot save you now.
Wait, what?
Whoa.
Oh, he's...
He's dead.
Oh, my God, he's dead.
Oh, my God, he died of cringe, too.
Everybody's dying of cringe.
Oh, my God, it's so loud.
I just cannot.
I liked how they were like, I picked between Joe and Charlie
and they're already dead
This isn't the ship we're at a mansion now Do they still
make these games I don't know I know they're doing really
bad right now I saw the reviews for it the newer episodes
were not doing so well oh who's this guy he isn't he the guy
that was the the psychiatrist and until dawn oh is he could
be I think so Oh, apparently we're gonna get a copyright
strike because of the song I turned it down.
It's okay.
They're just gonna get our ad money.
That's right?
Look at the the ring girl.
What is going on?
Is this like some like paranormal activity?
Is this like the video game version of like the Annabelle
chip and the nun.
What were they called?
They had names.
They were like a couple that investigated paranormal
activities.
Yeah, yeah.
Anne and Lorraine Warren or whatever.
What was the name of those movies called?
Well, they're just Annabelle, right?
No.
They had a name.
It was a series before Annabelle.
The conjuring.
The conjuring, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That's us.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're the conjuring.
we're the conjurers joe and charlie who died walking down
his own hallway so dramatic yeah oh now he's lighting
candles hello is the sound welcome yeah thank you to my
repository okay okay his suppository is that the things you
stick up your ass
If you're wondering why I know this, guys, it's because I
watch a lot of doctor shows.
Yeah, that's the only reason you know.
Then why do you know it, huh?
The curator of stories.
Yeah, but you're not answering the question, man.
You're not answering.
Wait, what did you say?
Why did you know what suppositories are?
Oh, because I watched the shows with you.
Oh, true.
Oh, yeah, you were there.
The story you choose to tell.
is only part written he's breaking the fourth wall make will
complete he's talking to us yeah whether the lives of those
with whom you are interfering continue to fly not our fault
they died or crunched out snuffed out you see we each make
decisions according to our own moral compass i think i have
a great you literally couldn't press a it was a lot of
pressure okay It is the tax one pays for how we live and it
comes eventually to everybody.
Still, none of us want for it to come too soon.
Yeah, mint.
Hey, hey, hey, I'm already dead.
I fear nothing.
Sometimes separately, what one does may not make complete
sense to the other because we all have different
perspectives.
Yeah, anything you do makes no sense to me.
And neither does you.
That's why it's perfect.
We're playing this.
Yeah, it's perfect I think the goal is to at least have one
person survive Probably but I might be persuaded who will it
be you?
Here's one for free.
Oh, there are pictures in this world that can show you some
possible future.
Oh Oh, so it's like a hint Yeah, they may just help you to
make better decisions.
Oh, no.
I think that's subjective if they're better or not.
Yeah Like, how do we know if they're better decisions?
Yeah.
That's all for the moment.
We'll talk again soon enough.
We'll have the opportunity to account for all the actions
that you've taken.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Thank you, man of Madan.
Do we need to pay you now?
Or like...
I don't know this guy.
Is this a trial period?
Oh, there's...
That's where we were.
That's the opening screen.
It was just the water.
Ooh.
Doki Bird is Alex.
I'm... You're Brad?
I'm Brad!
You're Brad!
I'm probably really cool.
Which one is this?
Brad's have cool... Brad's are a cool name, you know.
Is this the Brad or the Alex?
Oh, I look like a nerd!
I'm your brother.
We're brothers.
Brothers... Brad's brother.
How do we always end up being brothers?
Wait, which one is that you are you the nerd?
Yes, look at this nerd.
Oh my god, witty.
Wait, you're insecure.
You're insecure.
Why does yours says innocent?
Like what does that imply about me?
I'm an innocent maiden.
Down.
Diving.
Or maybe you could show me how the pros do it.
Ooh.
Doki Bird is the Let's see.
You didn't take lessons?
Kind of, yeah.
You think I can like just save you like that?
I'm gonna say nothing.
That's right.
Know your place, nerd.
That guy cam is like super expensive.
Oh, yeah.
I'm an influencer.
You're an influencer?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I have a camera.
So don't sweat the little stuff, man.
It's not cool.
Don't make me regret letting you tag along.
Yeah.
Don't make me regret it.
Are you deciding again?
Yeah.
You know, I'm not like the best around new people.
Oh, you're anxious.
We're excited.
Maybe feel better.
Oh, we're buddies.
Wait, I can see your traits.
Oh, that's what you're looking at.
What was it, RB?
Yeah, RB.
Wait, we have secrets, too.
I can't see it since I'm in the party.
Oh, my God.
I'm guarded, genuine.
I'm genuine, insecure, generous.
Who the fuck is Conrad and Fliss?
We're, we have, like, other people.
We're not there yet.
We have other people.
Alex reminded Brad he's not just a tagalog.
Alex was annoyed that Brad had not taken diving lessons.
oh my god come on i can't even see them now i'm gonna see it
now you're gonna see it it's rb it's collections and
characters that's what it was i'm eager i'm innocent yeah
but are you genuine like me you're not genuine mine
literally says genuine if you're not genuine oh you can't
see it we can only see each ourselves mine says guarded
generous genuine yeah i'm generous i mean i let you come
over to the diving to the diving place okay i could let you
drown if i wanted to because you're my bro i mean you're my
bro you're my brother see i'm being supportive i mean like
we're buddies you know yeah i'm like i'm a buddy oh i'm here
to hang cool out and kick it Yeah, you gotta loosen up, bro.
Let's just kick it and be legends, man.
You're Apex Legends?
All right, amigo.
Sorry, I'm a little snappy.
I'm just, when you medical school, be stressful, you know?
I'm in medical school!
I'm a doctor!
Oh my god!
At least I'm a cool nerd.
You're a fucking influencer.
It's been like two weeks, come on, man.
Yep.
Right on cue.
i'm smart and cool what are you i'm innocent i'm gonna be a
doctor i'm gonna save lives you need to save your own first
so uh can i get your input on something oh my god i propose
just uh oh you are a big thing i'm trying to make a decision
about yeah finishing med school no but it's just kind of a
big life choice you know okay i don't know what's the right
thing to do oh my god do i marry her or not i'm gonna say
nothing wow you're so supportive oh my god that's my
girlfriend julia your girlfriend julia that's her brother
he's relaxed he's foolhardy what oh yo you want me to hook
you up with her brother Oh, wow.
Oh, you like that.
This is Alex.
Hey, what's up, man?
Conrad.
Yeah.
Lady killer.
Right here.
Oh, that's me.
He's ignoring you.
This Conrad guy looks like, um, he looks like that actor.
I've heard so much about you.
Dr. Horrible.
Dr. Neopatric Harris.
Yeah, Neopatric Harris.
Miss me.
Of course.
I'm cracking a cold.
one every second every second i love you i'm gonna i'm gonna
be cool i'm gonna be cool you guys minutes way less needy oh
no she called me needy
i'm not needy i swear i think this is my first time having a
beer are you know what you just cracking a beer yeah i'm
having i'm cracking one with a cold one oh wait i'm oh i
thought throwing up i can't believe it wait who's that who's
this this is my love interest now captain of the duke of
milan oh dang oh shit badass oh my gosh see your tattoo yeah
i'd invite you to make yourselves at home but uh why why is
everyone yeah Isn't she like, yeah, isn't she the captain?
Yeah, you don't know who's sailing the ship.
Like, what's going on?
Here we go.
You're selling, I'm buying.
Whoa!
I hope Conrad dies first.
Yeah, me too.
Conrad, that's fucked up.
Do not flirt with the person who knows how to drive the
boat.
Yeah.
What are we doing here anyway?
We're diving, is that it?
Yeah, we're learning how to dive.
Cool.
the duke of milai oh oh that's you no that's you you're that
in the blue shirt what a fucking dude look she's like
comforting man she likes it when they're weak
oh what about over here what is this that's pretty far she's
through the pics can you see me going through the pics no
i'm fucking talking to the captain right now i'm looking at
some oh usually these things are falling with divers yeah
this is different i'm just saying if it gets too late i know
some nice places where you can just you know come here a
nice dive i think it's hot diggity dog wait you did your
homework if he says a wreck's here it's here oh yeah we got
a wreck we got a Diving you have you suggested the captain
said it's not a good idea, but I trusted you mint I trusted
your call cool If we die, it's on you
Oh, I'm looking at the pictures now.
Yeah, Brad's calculations were right on the money always bet
on Brad See I'm smart Brad is smart We found a plane.
Yeah, I don't know the captain was like not a great idea
Technically, we should call this in to port authorities as
an unreported wreck.
Oh.
Wow.
Don't keep her deciding.
Don't let Don't keep her deciding.
I'm going to be disappointed.
Are you saying we shouldn't die?
Oh, why am I Conrad?
Oh, my God.
Wait, you're Conrad now?
Look, I think we got to listen to our experience.
Oh, mint.
Beautiful.
I mean, she is beautiful.
What decision did you make?
Because she's beautiful.
I mean, she is beautiful.
But that's like a coincidence.
Oh my god.
Hey, I'm Conrad now.
I have to do what I have to do.
We're done.
Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna marry a bitch.
I just can't wait.
She's like a Karen for me.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna marry a Karen.
Then why did you not say anything?
Why?
Why did you say nothing when I asked you?
I'll set up the tanks.
The boys will do the final check.
It's not my call.
Take a look at the camera.
See if you can find anything.
That one second loading screen there.
Yeah, what the hell is that?
Maybe you should check on your bro.
Yeah, where's my, where's the bro?
Where's Brad?
Oh shit.
Oh.
Brad, where are you?
Where are you, Brad?
Oh, look at the binoculars.
The way you, like, walk and glide around.
Ooh.
I'll find you later.
I'm looking at the binoculars.
I'm looking at the pictures again.
I like the pictures.
I'm an iPad kid.
Ooh, that opening.
Okay, we got it.
Okay.
This is...
like such a tiny ship where could brad go i think he's
laying down oh i'm stuck oh wait where am i wait hey i'm
gonna talk to my girlfriend me too you're like you're
vibrating
need a hand i'm in this conversation too let me in i think
we're in good shape it's probably not a bad idea oh i'm
actually in the conversation Hey, hey, JJ.
You all right?
JJ.
Gotta say, not too happy with our captain at the moment.
She's right there.
Wait, what?
Where are you deciding?
I'm going to be annoyed.
Are you going to be white knight here?
We paid top dollar to come out here in the middle of nowhere
to do whatever the hell we want without any Nambi Pambi's
breathing down our neck.
That's the good old American way.
I'm serious, Connie.
All right.
I'm going to get these re-breather set up, and then we'll go
through the final steps together.
Great.
I'm going to kick back and...
Enjoy the sights for a little while.
I can't believe the captain didn't even hear that.
I know, me too.
Captain like a great ape creep.
He admits to being a creep.
Oh my god, he's self-aware.
He's actually self-aware.
I'm trying to go to Brad.
I want to talk to him.
I want to look at the weather.
Going to Brad.
I'm going to Brad.
All right.
Oh, I turned it off.
Wait, I think I see a picture.
Wait, hold on.
This is one of those sneaky pictures.
what's this oh what's this what are you looking at i'm
handing over i unlocked a premonition oh that's gonna help
me us with decisions remember yeah but i want to see so i
know that you won't fuck up he was he's gonna be in here
what's his premonition wait that's brad yeah i don't it it
doesn't do anything what does that mean what the what does
that mean I'm trying to make a decision.
I'm trying to look at a premonition right now.
I'm making a decision.
Okay.
Brad's like in the bathroom.
I'm going to be a dick to him.
You've been a dick to my bro.
You're going to be a dick to yourself?
I hate myself.
The sales of a seafaring gal.
You got that whole brainiac thing going on.
That's nothing to sneeze at.
Don't worry, Stud.
He's all yours.
Oh, why did he do that with his face?
What's this?
Oh, there's Cologne.
Captain Kiss?
I'm looking at Cologne while you're bullying yourself.
Where are you?
I was opening the closet.
There's another room here.
Oh, I'm going in.
Yeah, now I'll talk to my little bro.
Yeah, what's this?
How you doing?
Sorry, that Beruski got the better.
Hello, Walker?
oh i'm going through people's things that's really normal
all part of the adventure oh i'm looking at the clone sorry
for putting a damper on things no worries dude do more than
that just a script trip just get some rest why am i going
through your stuff what the hell look i i comfort my bro
after you bullied him oh why are you looking at my stuff hey
hey hey i was just what are you doing what are you doing uh
up to code i'm just yeah yeah you were looking at my cologne
i saw you looking at my cologne i i took your cologne oh you
took my cologne oh this door doesn't open yeah i think we
talked to our bros now what do we do i'm gonna go talk to
the captain okay i'm gonna watch you talk to the captain
okay i'm gonna watch you fair up yeah all right hey girl oh
captain my captain really get out of my gutsy
You showed me a little respect You're gonna show me a little
I agree Really?
Oh, captain by captain?
I like it when you're scared.
Hey, I like it when you're scared.
Sometimes I just want to be kept in line, you know what I'm
saying?
I don't mind a little submission now.
Oh my god!
Turn one off.
That thing where you have to hit on me like every two
seconds.
I think she likes it.
Bro.
So where is it working?
Where are you?
Come back to my...
Cutting.
Oh, there you are!
These rules are all pretty basic stuff.
How much experience do you have with these kind of dives?
Are you still talking to me?
Yeah!
Nothing is like my thing.
Pretty much an authority back home.
Oh yeah.
If you move around, does he move?
Why don't you want to follow the rules for unreported
wrecks?
But all you know, this could be a war.
Do you see me?
Yes!
I'm gonna be playful I'm still talking to her You've only
spoken to a woman before You've only talked to your sister
Damn It's my turn to talk to her now Alright you talk to her
You talk to her I'm watching I'm watching Wait no I'm stuck
Wait the cover stitch wait I'm stuck wait I can't progress
anything no you see me just looking around what are we on
what's going on what's going on no we broke the game fix it
fix it talk to our sister oh wait wait there you go there
you go there you go no i can't move i'm just you can't move
wait wait there's something over here hold on i'm gonna go
look at it yeah start start the next scene man start to the
next scene oh she said something oh what's going on oh my
god i'm looking at her driver's license you're looking at
her freak how do we start the next scene um hold on i just
doubted her credentials wait she's your sister what do you
mean you out in her credentials.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, you're still standing there.
Honey, how do we start the game?
I can't.
I'm gonna push you.
Push me into the bone.
I can't push you.
I can't.
I'm not gonna go talk to my sister.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We fixed it.
Don't be on here.
Oh my god, it's big.
Oh my god.
It's a regular scuba set up.
It takes all of the tools that you normally just
accidentally to the water.
And instead, it gets totally reused.
Okay.
We need to listen to our structures or we'll die.
Oh yeah, yeah, we have to do.
We won't die.
We won't die here.
Check done.
Okay.
I don't think I'm diving.
I'm not...
Are you gonna be my girlfriend now?
You gotta check your O2 first.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, okay.
Thanks for your sit.
playful i'm gonna be playful i'd like to take you underwater
oh bro you were what the you were like creeping on the
captain earlier about this drive this is the line this is
the line at the dive cam i saw this huge hole in the tail
kabooy kabooy nice work man thanks conrad okay you little
clown fishes i'm gonna go see what fliss is up here right
after defending you So you're like, anyway, I'm gonna hit
it.
I'm up the captain again.
I'm gonna be cheery.
Wait, what's the baton stick or the camera?
We don't need a camera.
We're gonna need that baton.
I don't know what this is.
A bangstick.
Ha ha.
You ever have to use one?
On a shark?
Nope.
Okay, are you going in?
Take the camera or Julia?
Why is the lighting really?
All of a sudden.
I can't even know what's happening.
This better not be pissy this whole thing.
Why is the lady so sorry?
I don't know.
Why is she just looking at us like that?
I think she's nervous.
I got a bag.
sick i got sick that that bangs uh-huh yeah
julia liked it last night
wait so am i doing nothing nice all right it's up to you
don't wait a minute you were brad now comrade and now julia
like pick a lane there's no way there's no way Oh my god,
there's dead bodies in here.
Is this Madonna?
No, this is a plane.
It's a plane?
Yeah.
Why are we going in here?
Because we found this wreck.
Here we go.
Down we go.
Why are we diving when it's the sun setting?
Should we just wait for a day?
Are you still talking to her?
No, I'm watching the cutscene.
command no oh oh you're gonna need to use your bag stick
seafaring client is requesting the pleasure of your company
over a frosty amber liquid the the boat looks really far
away wait i'm gonna be okay um all right you know what sure
i'll give you one wait are you on the boat yeah i'm i'm We
know why somebody died.
It's a long story.
It's complicated and it's really difficult to explain.
Well, I'm a complicated guy.
Doki bird is fliss.
Why am I?
Why am I Julia?
All of a sudden.
You're the Karen.
Oh my God.
You're smarter than you look.
If you're interested.
Here I go.
I'm going inside the queue.
Oh my God.
Comrade's like.
Comrade wants to invest in my business.
What?
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, I want Conrad's money Oh, I almost just killed
Julia, I think I suppose you could have that conversation Oh
my god, that scared me Oh my god, I just noticed something
was wrong I better spend some time keeping the Duke of Milan
Shipshake Explore the plane wreck
Alright Let's see, wait for the others to return from the
dive Oh, you are doing, why are you doing the action part?
I don't know Why am I doing the action part I'm just
chilling.
I'm just chilling on the ship right now.
Oh, wait.
What was that?
Oh, I can talk to you.
You can?
Yeah.
Duke to Alex.
Duke to Julia.
I didn't hear.
Do you guys hear me?
Oh, I heard it.
I heard it.
We're looking at a hole.
Don't ignore her.
Ignore Fliss.
You're going to ignore me?
She's angry.
I'm going to call you guys again.
You think you can...
You're talking to me.
you could just ignore me like that ring ring ring oh you
gotta ghost me now yeah i'm doing risky business okay don't
be such a go now don't you think i'm not gonna spam call you
now
oh my god i think she might die don't worry don't worry i'm
calling you again don't don't be such a gonad okay if you
guys dies not me i got it okay let's see what's this oh
those are the photos oh i'm lost wow oh he's here every day
wreck you're a good boyfriend he gave me oh nice you're
gonna now you're gonna kill fucking alex you're gonna kill
alex i spent so much i spent a lot of difficult decisions to
get alex to where he's at and now you're just gonna kill him
off she is so rude i told you she's such a karen i hope she
dies this this oh without a secret yeah yeah because i did
risky business i told you oh i'm lagging oh my god what's
happening okay go easy on the booze i'm gonna i'm bullying
brad right now see it's easy to bully him well let's avoid
that tube what do you know brad what do you know brad he
doesn't know anything is brad and theories i got tired of
the speculation and wanted to see if there was actually
anything there okay oh oh the ship is around world war two
yeah right because uh how did you figure it out everyone was
just looking at where the plane was headed but i asked
myself oh god what is it i'm using my bang stick i'm using
my bang stick i made some guesses based on my hypothetical
return flight and you're lucky you're welcome i got you that
bang stick i did it i i used it did you like it oh my god
it's a dead man by the thrill of finding a wreck um she's
banging she's banging i'm banging uh i'm investigating the
ghost um what what happened an eel an eel attacked me all i
get is the ship with conrad you get to explore i had to deal
with conrad
it's not fair i'm just saying maybe you should have picked
uh brad instead you can monitor the guy some boat
maintenance not a bra bob investigate him please investigate
i'm trying to so are you beached so are you beached like a
whale hey i just thought why spend all my time i'm piloting
the plane i already like what i see up top oh my god Oh my
god.
Should I hit on should I hit on Conrad?
Yeah, do I do it?
I'm gonna hit on Conrad.
Do it do it do it Oh my god Conrad said he'll like invest in
my business Oh my god You're in you're in I'm in Oh my god
my business is gonna flourish now I like how the girl was
just like It's not like we're gonna ruin the ship or
anything And here I go like ruining the ship I like how like
I'm also being your wingman right now Oh, he's holding
something his wife.
Oh my god He's in Right how to turn this on Am I just
waiting on you guys to return to the ship like what am I
doing here?
I'm just literally waiting Guys hurry up Didn't didn't
what's his name say that like wrecking wreck Like, diving
was his thing.
Oh, there's pirates!
What?
Uh-oh.
What do you mean there's pirates?
Like, yo-ho.
That's not the Coast Guard.
The Coast Guard.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
What do you mean?
So we're not under arrest.
Oh, I think.
Mint.
I'm stuck.
I think.
Do I need to come back?
You should call me back.
Pirates are not doing anything.
You should call and say like, hey.
So you be quiet and let me handle it.
Give me, get up here.
You got that?
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, what's going on?
There's pirates.
I fucked up whoa whoa whoa whoa they're moving the ship
they're moving the the plane oh my god they're destroying it
wait what they're destroying the plane who's who's there
who's they I don't know something something pulled come at
me shark it's not a problem what do you think like ten bucks
cover it wow you guys a doctor and also a marine biologist
how does he know everything okay mint we're coming back mint
um comrades a he's antagonizing the pirates
oh my god i think i think alex is trying to propose under
here in the in the water to propose um oh my god you i don't
know what to say what i'm just gonna say nothing they left
didn't they that doesn't make you any less of an idiot you
got a funny way of saying thank you oh he gave up okay um
seriously what's going on what's going on what is going on
dad there's so many things going on i know when you think of
something i'll just be over here taking My relationship with
Alex is going down.
My relationship with Conrad is also going down.
It's nice to know we're both sabotaging each other's
relationships.
I know.
It's fine.
I can make it up.
I make it up in Denkull.
Whatever you say to her doesn't mean anything.
Oh my god.
Conrad's fucking...
Oh!
And he's fucked up.
I'm more like you.
What do you mean?
I'm controlling the captain.
Oh.
I don't even get to make a choice.
Um, I'm going.
I'm going.
He's like, we gotta decompress.
I'm sorry.
She's heroic.
Oh, and Alex is just like chilling in the water.
Wait.
I'm like stuck on, okay.
all right comrade it's going downward guys i'm messing up
comrade after all the hard work i did flirting uh hey jj
don't worry about it what's going on why did they go you
know you set money in the yeah what's that money for
i'm altruistic now yeah for real um It was Conrad's fault.
It wasn't.
So, why are you paying the ocean?
Yeah.
Why are you paying the ocean?
A fishing boat came by and got damaged on the dive line.
Oh, that's what happened.
Yeah.
They were being a little surly about it, so Conrad made it
rain and they pissed off.
Wow.
They didn't even take the money.
What I want to know is what you guys find.
Yeah, what did you find?
We found the plane.
And it is huge.
Full of cool stuff.
Yeah, like eels and sharks apparently.
yeah what why the dive line actually yeah the dive line how
bad uh there's no cockpit anymore for starters well that's
just fucking perfect well that's not our fault like we
didn't do that you're the captain of the ship well how is it
my fault yeah carred fucking threw money on the ship oh hey
here's the did we do okay yeah how we do man what do we do
he's laughing at us you're getting to know these intrepid
adventurers then yeah and his little brother brad are we
doing okay with the big fish both seem out of their depth
yeah and julia the love of alex's life and i don't know
after what meant it i don't know about that it's not one
diving trip that's gonna destroy their relationship and then
there's captain fliss strong forthright stubborn stubborn do
i detect a spark between her and connor we're gonna force
them to like each other wait we have a special feature
unlocked that's a special feature some i think they may
regret his jacket looks like a giraffe like a cantaloupe
skin apparently we made some decisions that they're gonna
regret later no i mean I think you made some decisions that
are gonna regretfully.
No.
It was like traveling through time.
No shit.
Well, it was like traveling through time and accidentally
ending up in a dimension where the past is underwater and
like everything is covered in barnacles.
I think Julia's stupid.
Well, I like them stupid.
It was like traveling to the past where everything is
underwater and everything's covered in barnacles.
And sharks.
I can't believe there's sharks in the ocean.
Did you know that?
Yeah, I've been studying it for years.
I'll go look for him.
I didn't even meet...
Oh, wait.
I'm Brad now.
Wait, who are you?
I'm watching...
Oh, I'm Julia.
I'm Julia.
You're Julia?
You got the short end of the stick.
I'm going to eavesdrop.
I can read you from a mile away.
Oh, wait.
Why are you in my cutscene?
I could see you.
What's going on?
Don't fuck this up.
Privacy.
Oh,
okay, don't worry.
I'll watch from here.
Yeah, maybe.
I think so.
Oh, you know so.
Oh my god.
Is everything okay?
I see you in the car.
Yeah, is everything okay?
What are you gonna do?
Man, you have ruined a 10-year relationship?
That's fine.
It's fine.
What's going on?
Look, when we get home, we can talk about some stuff.
What do you mean we can talk about some stuff?
I mean, it's not like we're breaking up.
Man, what are you doing?
No.
What are you doing to our relationship?
Stuff.
Got it.
Oh, my God.
This guy...
He acts like an AI for real.
Brad is right there.
Oh, my God.
Or Fliss?
Uh, no, I...
Yeah, I got distracted.
Let's go get him.
I got distracted with this conversation.
Are they?
Oh!
I did that.
You're welcome, man.
I worked so hard on this for you.
Christ, Conrad.
What did he do?
What's going on?
Interrupt your seven seconds in heaven.
Oh, yeah, the beers.
I was just getting them now.
We're not going to address that.
Oh, man, you worked so hard and I brought it home run.
I brought it home for you.
And you tried to sabotage it after I worked so hard for it.
It's a seven-year relationship.
If they weren't going strong, they would.
My intervention would mean nothing.
Maybe we can figure out why the flames aren't.
What happened underwater, man?
What happened?
Oh, search for the nav pad.
You got the nav pad, Master J?
Oh, no.
Not yet.
What's that?
What's the nav pad?
Oh, this thing.
You all right?
You seem kind of pre-op.
Yeah.
I'm grabbing it.
Sorry.
Wait, is this it?
I'm realizing I'm spacing out.
What is this?
I'm talking to my brother.
What am I doing?
How do you think the day went?
Oh, I'm looking at the pictures.
Other than our little day-to-day with the locals.
Pretty good.
People always say they had dive experience, but Alex and
Julia seems to actually know what they're doing.
Conwin Islands.
So...
Oh, that's me.
We're going again tomorrow?
That's me.
Oh, I can't wait.
Sign me.
That's me.
Can't wait to see this sucker for myself.
What are you doing, man?
We're having a conversation with everybody except for Julia.
Oh, sorry.
I was looking at pictures.
Why?
Yeah.
Oh, I thought it was a tablet.
Well, I mean, I did.
What?
See, I did that.
What did you do?
Women, right?
Oh, I'm making out with Alex right now.
Right here.
Wait, you kissed Alex?
Yeah.
You fixed it.
Fix the problem you caused Well, yeah, no, I was I did it I
caused that I mean Yes, yeah, you did you did cause it It's
blooming, it's blooming If you did decompress too fast then
you should go easy on the beer Alex, I'm fine I think if I
got the bends I would know by now I think I'm fine Not
always Sometimes the bends can be super delayed It could be
hours or a day or two The bends Yeah, what's the bends?
It's when you come up from a dive too fast Oh, yeah, uh,
decompression sickness.
Oh, nerd.
Nerd.
Wow, they're all in all caps.
It's really serious.
I always get sick and die from decompression sickness every
year.
And that is why the good Dr. Conrad says drink him.
If you got him, because either you're fine or you're going
to want a little sick.
I don't think I want to listen to Dr. Conrad.
Yeah.
I think Alex is an actual dog.
Take orders from this guy.
Just drink a beer.
Bro, what?
Oh, no, I have to make the decision.
Man, don't you dare.
You got to listen to Conrad.
Nerd!
Are you scared?
Oh my god!
If she dies, it's on you!
Literally doctors orders and you're like, bureaucrat!
Let me listen to my brother who throws money at problems.
Hey, I'm not Julia.
You'll be Julia eventually too.
I have to be Julia to take care of the mess you made.
Reckless.
All of you.
Excuse me.
I told you to leave everything down there alone.
Oh, come on.
We've been through this already.
I'm not talking about the law.
Superstition?
Wait.
Is that it?
Really?
The dead don't sleep well in these waters.
May sound silly enough to you all, but I was raised on this
shit and it sticks.
Oh Are you gonna call her like a liar?
Come on Maybe it's not Julia being a Karen.
Maybe it's you It's a Karen No respect for anyone else's
traditions I just don't like Julia.
I don't want anyone else to like Julia either.
You think you can scavenge down there and it makes no
difference but every single thing you bring back has an
essence.
It's like a ghost you invite to the surface.
Here we go.
Huh.
Oh my god, you're so rude.
of anything you're so rude you made it rude people drown in
these waters and you have to respect their resting place
damn straight friend you got a fun ghost story right oh i do
do you come on decide say yeah yeah i'll go once upon a time
yeah come on let's hear it oh oh yeah let's hear it Let's
hear it.
Let's hear it.
I bet you can spin a good yarn.
It's kind of messed up, actually.
Yeah.
Scared away, little bro.
Okay.
Here goes.
This story is true.
It had happened right near here in an old lighthouse.
Classic setup.
True story?
Where'd you hear this?
I saw Alex already knew the story.
Why are you deciding?
A creepy old guy.
Well, down by the dockside, I found an ancient old man.
Skin like a letter book.
Why did your wiggle up?
For just a dollar.
Okay.
The lighthouse stood atop an atoll, isolated from the rest
of the world.
Because it was a spooky lighthouse.
Yeah.
The lighthouse keeper would hear the waves pounding the
rocky shore.
One misty morning, he comes upon a woman, covered in blood.
Ooh, women?
He hurries to her aid and she falls into his arms, sobbing.
Oh my god.
As he hurries her back to the lighthouse, he asks where
she's from.
He doesn't waste any time.
Ha!
Conrad, shut up, Conrad.
Yeah, shut up.
Shut up.
My parents are upstairs right now.
Dun, dun, dun, dun.
The lighthouse keeper says, That isn't so.
Of course, he's lived there alone for years.
And the woman becomes hysterical.
And his pupils are so dialy.
So, they go to the top of the lighthouse.
And there, splayed out on the floor, is a man and a woman.
Oh My god, I mean do people even use X's anymore?
I'm just for I'm just reporting the facts Chopped up into
little tiny giblets we have an axe giblets It's a good story
man.
It's a very good story Wow you tell a better story then
You're the one that asked for the story No, Julia, like,
relationship went up.
Say it was you.
Oh, I'm going to do relax.
The woman says, it was my husband.
And she turns to the closet.
It says, he's in there.
Yeah.
The husband.
And that's why I've always been a little weary of marriage.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no, Alex, no.
Alex is putting his head in his hands right now.
He's not.
What?
But he's cut his own.
throat oh he looks closer to see the dead man's face in the
dark closer closer and he sees oh my god the uncanny i know
and then it's eyes bulge out and screams what the fuck where
did that come from i think brad is possessed yeah i think i
think he's possessed holy shit Oh, come on.
That wasn't scary.
Okay.
Do better next time, Brad.
Doki, pick better proms next time.
Wow, I saw you scream.
I saw the screams around me.
One more beer before hitting the hay.
What regular issues are these?
It's standard issue regulatory.
I don't think I trust Conrad with anything.
I don't either.
I feel like he's like that type of boy.
that's like, I'm going to tell my dad what you said about
me.
Do we not notice the storm that's incoming?
And we're on a tiny little boat that's going to capsize.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Now there's a storm.
I think we're in trouble.
I think we fucked up.
I think we messed up, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
You think those guys are going to come back and...
The fishermen?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Where did they come from?
Did you bring stuff up to the ship?
And what's the tablet?
You brought a tablet?
That's why we looked at the gold!
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
They have opposable thumbs.
They're fine.
We're fine.
They're looking over us.
I don't feel fine.
Is that the ship here?
Is that the... That light looks human.
Wait, those... Are they the pirates?
He's got a gun, that's, oh my god, oh, oh, oh, what do I,
what do I, oh, oh, I tried right triggering, but it didn't
let me do anything.
I think he's about to die.
What did you do?
I, did you not do your quick time offense?
I couldn't figure out where I was supposed to go!
Oh my god, I did my quick time!
Wait, help!
Oh, look at where it's gotten you, you're still trapped too.
quick dive event I'm trying to get the gun from his head
where's Brad oh there's Fliss oh there they are that's the
fisherman that's the pirates I told you this guy means
business why why'd you piss him off why did you piss him off
because you pissed him off you threw money at them it's
yours I couldn't control Conrad nobody can't control Conrad
That's your fault.
Oh, you're deciding.
Okay, call me.
I'm with your genius idea this time.
What is she doing?
She's crying on his...
What is happening?
I don't know.
I don't know!
I don't want to do this!
Oh, oh, but I missed my event.
That is my fault.
I'm trying to be in this hell right now!
Did you miss it?
You missed it!
There was no, okay, you are, you're so good at this.
You do it then.
You gotta see what I meant.
Yeah?
I did it!
How did you do it?
I had to choose between Conrad and Julia.
Okay, let me try this again.
Let me try this again.
How did you do it?
This is how we're gonna die.
I write trigger and then I pull with the right.
I'm trying to pull So it is your right.
I swear I'm doing I swear to God.
I swear to God This will never be All right, you fucking do
it again.
I'll do it.
I'll do it I do understand.
Okay, watch this.
It's so easy.
How did you do that?
How did you?
How did you do it?
Okay, your turn.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, no.
Oh, why is he bleeding?
Where's Brad?
Oh, no.
I gotta turn the sound down again on this thing.
It's so bad.
I don't know what you said.
How did you guys do it?
Wow, you let Fliss die because you couldn't un-gag her.
I didn't understand!
What is the good news?
I don't see how this could get me worse.
The bad news is these are kind of maybe the fishermen I
missed off earlier.
Oh my god, Conrad.
Crayed.
And the good news?
I recognize them.
What?
How's that good news?
How's that good news first?
They're such an idiot.
Jesus.
Oh, wait.
Um.
I'm going to untie him.
We have to get free right now.
Yeah, come here.
Come here, Conrad.
Put on some pants, man.
Wait, did you have to hold?
You hold down the right stick until it came off?
Yes!
Oh, why did you see that?
I told you!
Look, look.
I didn't realize you had to hold it.
Who's the game right now?
You fell your quick time event twice.
What?
It was just the gun.
Oh my god, this guy.
Oh.
Yeah, sit back down.
Sit back down, idiot.
Wouldn't they think it's weird that we're un-gagged?
I know, right?
Why don't...
Oh, what the?
I succeeded my quick time event.
Did you?
I did mine!
Okay.
I did mine, yeah.
I stopped you from getting beat up.
All right, Conrad.
Oh, he, Conrad kind of deserves it, though.
Wait, Conrad's gone.
Bye, Conrad.
Hi.
What did he...
wait are you getting taken away yeah i'm seeing what's
happening oh you can go yourself you piece of oh you're the
little lady what's happening oh so like the guy was like
you're oh and then conrad gets punched i saw that oh where's
he going oh my god they're taking him out i mean if they
kill conrad that's okay right like we're beating conrad we
don't We don't care about that, right?
I'm making Julia scared.
Okay, what do you want?
What do you fuckers want?
Okay, I didn't say fuckers.
I said...
Wait, they're actually killing Conrad.
Wait, they're actually killing Conrad!
You did this!
I just said, what do you want?
They're gonna...
Yeah, you pissed them off.
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait.
They have the gun?
Oh, no.
It's a knife.
Oh, my God.
They're going to kill Conrad.
I'm going to say nothing.
Don't say anything.
I want to say nothing.
If I say something, I feel like they're going to, they're
going to get agitated.
What is that?
I saved Conrad.
You're welcome.
No, why would you want to save Conrad?
Because you told me to.
You literally told me to.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
cuticle cutter i'm cutting the ropes i'm gonna say nothing
again oh they're coming back they're coming back they're
coming back i feel like if i say something i would they
would agitate him more oh he's coming back i'm back conrad
i'm back i saved conrad just for you men i'm because you
love conrad so much i want to see him get us killed even in
a different way I feel like, like, yeah, I feel like you
have higher survivability if he's dead.
Alex, why did you get up so slowly?
You have no restraints!
Well, just open the door!
Listen, Julia, breaking heads.
Not the other way around.
Flisher seems to be getting buddy-buddy with him.
Uh, wait.
What's going on?
You're in.
I'm with Conrad and Alex.
us oh wait whoa you're conrad no i'm alex oh i'm conrad
but i'm sure he's fine these guys probably just want money
or something yeah man if i let conrad die here i would not i
wouldn't have to be forced to play conrad everyone has to
play conrad at least one even you chat everyone has to feel
the shame I thought by saving Conrad, you will have to deal
with Conrad later.
No, they knew that you liked him so much.
I literally saved him for you!
What did they do to Julia?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, little Julia?
Hey, hey, are you okay?
Are you okay, little girl?
They didn't touch me.
Okay.
They asked about our parents.
What?
what do they have oh it's going to be a hostage situation
yeah there you go nice what if everybody dies but conrad
should we do that make it our mission is keep conrad alive
is he just counting yeah what is he counting oh i think he's
seeing the time between the lightning in the thunder oh
that's smart yeah he is wow spoken like a true conrad wow
nerd maybe we can take it yeah yeah it's a speedboat the
main guy here he's got a gun uh-oh um uh i'm gonna you know
well at least one of us can get on their boat we're gonna
get on that boat right the okay i'm gonna say nothing so You
have to get on the boat.
Oh, what do you think?
She's asking you.
I can get out through the window.
We got to break these off first.
Oh, that's you.
That's you.
No, I didn't say anything.
Yes, you're going to get through the window.
Yeah, good call.
Good call.
No, Conrad.
Conrad the go.
No, I said nothing.
Okay, sneaking mission.
Oh, no.
Sneaky.
Oh, no, please.
I don't want to be comrade anymore Three no, I have to be
Conrad Uh-oh, uh-oh Go Conrad go go Conrad go Go Conrad go
Oh Is this me?
Is this my quick time event?
Oh shoot Ah Don't fuck this up Don't fuck this up Don't fuck
this up Don't fuck this up Um, I might have fucked it up a
little What did you do?
I'm doing my quick time event right now I thought it said X.
What did you do?
I'm escaping.
Get out of here.
Get out of here, Conrad.
Go live.
Live a long life.
Oh, wait.
I did it.
I think Fliss is going to die.
I have a hostage.
I went.
I went escape.
I didn't grab a knife.
What?
I mean!
What did you mean?
Wait, what did you do?
I have a guy hostage, I'm gonna kill him.
Oh my God, there you are, like Spider-Man.
Goodbye.
Ah, Comrade's leaving.
Wait, I think they're gonna shoot me.
No!
They're gonna shoot Comrade!
Attack him!
I don't care about you, Julie.
Oh, I tried.
I really did try it.
Oh my god.
Is he dead?
Did you dodge it?
God Red's escape!
We did it!
We saved Conrad!
She died!
Conrad lived!
Neither of us have to play as him again.
We did it, guys.
Thank God I was Conrad and doing a quick time event I saved
you I could have shielded Julia But I saved you instead Yeah
because you know we needed to save Conrad He's gone oh my
god He's gone his little big adventure He's just Conrad Oh
my god we did it guys Apparently people were like People
usually never save Conrad.
He usually dies there.
Conrad deserves better.
Conrad?
We did it, guys.
He's gonna be the hero in the end.
Yeah.
He's gonna do it.
Is the sound effects down real quick?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm turning them down again.
I'm gonna turn down as well.
I can't believe it.
They're like usually Conrad gets shot I don't know how you
guys see
We have our priorities straight Absolutely The only two
people who saved Conrad
Willingly not for like completionist sake
okay we're hostages uh cool what do we do now she's like
looking for him why do you make all the important decisions
why can't you wipe the blood off your face we were only
talking there's no harm in just talking you want to talk
yeah we practically won the game we have one survivor so we
basically what i'm just gonna say it fliss has got to be in
on this
i bet you told them about the minchurian gold they don't
even know about the gold why did you tell them about the
gold oh my god well please what do you have to say believe
what i'm hearing i just lost everything i have and this is
what you think you're what do you mean you lost everything.
See, I lost my boat.
This is my boat.
Oh, dang it.
That quick time event was to save Julia.
Come with me.
Oh, Phyllis again.
Cahoot, cahoot, cahoot.
What happened to Brad?
Oh, he's so...
Brad is right next to me.
Why not?
Why won't you talk to me?
Move the gun.
We should save Julia next.
Save all the worst people.
They can have each other.
Julia and her brother.
How bad is the storm?
Hey, uh, just requesting any information about this storm
you can give us.
Why do you like this?
I don't know, I'm just talking to you, man.
Um, uh, should I provoke them, guys, or what should I do?
I literally was compliant.
I'm not.
Uh, okay.
discord here we can handle a couple of bucks and drops of
rain uh thanks for the info we'll see you for drinks come on
talk to me look i'm being compliant i listen being a little
baby what the are you doing down there why are you trying to
make sure we don't die and you're on your feet you're
antagonizing the other pirate oh oh oh oh my god oh oh quick
time event quick time
I'm I got my both mine did you I got mine too okay all right
I doubt it at
least you're downstairs I'm upstairs what our ship is
flooding we're gonna drown wait what's going on the ship is
flooding oh my god oh my god there you guys are oh we're
drowning we're drowning we're drowning i'm gonna hold on i'm
gonna rescue um Brad instead Hope you guys are okay because
I I had a choice to save but I chose not to
Why was there so much water in there because we're in the
ocean I had to help Brad
What did I do?
I literally saved us by...
Brad can't help himself.
He's a little baby.
Uh-oh.
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, we found the ship.
Oh my god, we found Madonna!
Yeah!
There's Madonna!
There it is.
Oh my god, get in there.
Whoa!
There's Madon!
The man, that was the man of him!
Yeah, that's the man!
The man of the Madon!
Oh my god, wait, that wasn't Conrad, you don't think, right?
No, because the one!
No, we saved him!
Did we save him?
Yeah!
We did it!
We're keeping people alive!
I think he's disappointed in us.
I think he wanted Conrad to die.
You appear to have saved Samara.
Oh, a bold move that paid off.
We mean, yeah, I saved Samara.
I would have done it too if it wasn't.
Yeah, it was a quick time event.
I don't think you would have.
I did all my quick time events.
Most of them.
The time-hearted creature I am, I'd like to offer.
you some oh okay warning of what's to come do you want to
see it oh oh oh wait um do you want to know or not i want to
know how do you okay let's let's know curious i got to make
the decision yeah in agreement clue it is yeah clue the
merchant of venice act two scene seven the prince of morocco
pulls a scroll from the eye of a skull and reads all that
glisters is not gold glisters often have you heard that tone
the fuck does that mean i don't what anyway what that was a
hint that's not even a bit it's barely a riddle what the
thing everything may not be entirely he quoted smash mouth
all that glisters is gold
Probably shouldn't have said that.
Oh, don't be greedy.
I meant don't be greedy.
I'm not.
Did you get the tablet?
I had to to progress.
I think.
Oh, yeah, I did.
You're Julia now.
Oh, no.
You're Fliss.
Oh, I'm Fliss now.
Okay, this is my first time being Fliss.
Oh, no.
Now I'm Julia.
Now to fix the relationship you've ruined.
Like I said, if they were truly happy for those seven years,
my little tiny decisions did nothing.
But how many tiny decisions did you make?
There was like...
No decisions.
Why are we going to that ship?
Why can't we stay in our little ship?
What is that?
Oh, what they- It's a dynamite, isn't it?
What?
I don't think so.
What was that?
Why did they suddenly decide to search in there?
I know, that's what I'm seeing.
Why can't we just stay in our tiny ship?
Oh, it's an engine part.
Oh!
Oh, apparently it was sinking.
What the hell is wrong with me?
Yeah, that's what I said, and you were like, we're in the
ocean!
How was I supposed to know we were sinking?
I thought just water got in!
Oh my god.
Yeah, we're all.
We're all gonna die in here.
Yeah, we're gonna die in the ship of Madonna.
But we know Brad would live in the bathroom here.
No, that was the bathroom of the other boat.
No, it was the bathroom of this boat.
No, I don't think so.
Right.
It was blue.
The ship is blue.
It was...
Oh, we're walking now.
Oh, we are.
I was just gonna stay here.
Hey, remember you can walk Faster, LB.
Oh.
LB.
I'm walking.
I'm walking here.
I got a thing.
What is this?
Guard duty.
Oh, he's watching me.
He's watching you?
Hey, I was reading that.
Yeah, stop reading.
This guy sucks.
Okay.
You're supposed to be walking.
I'm walking.
I'm doing my job.
I'm going to get tetanus.
Oh.
Who are you walking into?
Oh, I walk.
Oh.
He pushed me too.
Okay, my bad, my bad, my bad.
We're walking.
Apparently we can't even walk, right?
There we go.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no, your little bracelet.
Oh, my God.
No, my bracelet.
That's like $100,000.
Daddy bought it for me.
Real gold.
Yeah, I got it from...
What's wrong with your head?
Oh, that's a dead body.
Am I able to walk?
Am I walking?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
We were walking.
Oh, I got pushed back.
Sorry, I walked the wrong way.
You look a little worried.
What's wrong?
Where do we go?
Oh, Scooby.
What do you want to do?
What do you do?
Oh, gosh, Shaggy.
I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know about this, Shaggy.
Let's go.
Rocky.
I don't know about this, Waggy.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
what is that what is that i can move i want to see what the
poster says the mask of madness the man to look death in the
eye now showing in the mess hall whoa are you do you see
what i'm seeing i'm in the dormitories what are you saying i
don't know i'm not just walking oh i can there's an item
here rabbit oh there's no miller why are they like not
supervising us anymore i know where Are they?
Oh, I can also look at it.
What is it?
It says Miller Miller I'm waiting for you here.
I'm at the other side.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I'm coming Master Miller Oh, there's Alex They're slow.
They're just as slow as we are.
I don't think LB works.
I'll be honest.
I don't think so though I don't think it works either.
Why is every why is he moving like he's one of us like he's
moving like an MP.
Oh, there's rats Ruts?
Ruts?
Where's the watch, Rocky?
I didn't see any.
Oh, there's something over here.
Oh.
What's this?
It's an internal monol...
Memorandum.
This is gonna give us a hint.
You're covering Patterson's guard duties tomorrow.
He is sick again.
Conveniently, it's always when he has guard duties and hold
3A.
First, it's 24 o'clock.
Check the chart for rotation.
Oh.
Oh, you found a secret.
Maybe they'll help us.
This is the third time this week.
None of us like it down there.
Maybe Patterson should buck up.
Get, just get on it.
Okay.
Maybe they'll, maybe they'll, like, help us.
Hey, I want to look at the secret, too.
Yeah, go look at the secret.
I want to look at it.
How do I look at the secret?
It might be in the menu now, right?
No!
I think so.
Yeah, I think you got the secret, so I don't have to look at
the secret.
That's two for two secrets for me.
Oh.
Okay.
There's lots of doors here.
Yeah.
Are they putting us in the brig?
Wait, this is where we were, isn't it?
When we were Conrad and...
No, we were never here.
I don't remember this area.
Oh!
We locked in.
Oh my god.
Hey!
It's pitch black in here.
Give us the light.
Where did that light come from?
It doesn't look that dark.
Oh, they gave us a flat.
They're such nice pirates.
They're actually so nice.
See, their pirates aren't that bad.
I bet they weren't actually going to shoot Conrad.
Wait, how do we have a lighter?
Oh, gosh.
I almost missed that.
My controller was like, am I that?
How is that still good?
Like, not waterlogged.
I know.
Wait, maybe because the ship never went to the ocean.
um manchurian gold you're asked to have something to do with
the manchurian gold we're not far from those coordinates
anyone else creep the fuck out by this ship what's the
ship's name so was manchurian gold the name of the ship
that'd be a weird name i've seen some pretty weird names for
ships maybe you took a vote what's the ship's name oh wow
your relationship with alex went down what how did it go
down i literally just asked about name okay what is this
relationship we're trying to save huh to get us help we
should wait for him wait for brad um we should just leave i
didn't know that meant we call the ghost guard but the
duke's radio is shot we gotta find a radio on this ship oh
yeah good luck what's the status of the duke how would the
radio still be working i know right it's been like out of
commission for so lock.
Wait, I thought it was sinking.
If it was sinking, then how's ship going to be still there?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't think it was sinking.
I don't think so.
You told me it was sinking.
That's why I agreed with you.
You know what?
That told me it was sinking.
No, you said it first.
I was like, why don't we just say this shit?
But you're like, no, it's sinking, Doki.
What?
I mean, obviously that's not true.
They're being just as bad to you.
There was water.
We were drowning.
There's water everywhere.
Just get a fucking bucket.
Oh, my God.
It was Julius who was just like, we're going to drown.
Oh, hey, we apologized to each other.
After we were arguing with each other, they apologized.
I know.
but we did our job secured a room oh I got something here
too what's happening I don't know we're too busy arguing I
know okay what's this oh I found a secret hey baby doll I
miss you like crazy three months until my next leave and
jumping into your arms three months I've been on the shore
leave with these guys had a few beers but don't worry I'm
keeping everything ready for you if you catch my drift How's
work?
I hope that boss of yours is leaving you alone.
I know you can take care of yourself, but I feel helpless
being so far away, and I want to keep you safe.
Sky Miller was really freaked out.
I got a lot of time to think while I'm guarding the cargo
hulls.
It's dark and spooky down there.
Some of the other guys have seen a figure roaming around,
but I always got you with me to keep me safe, too.
I'll be with you soon, and get a job as a mechanic, and we
can get married and have two children.
We'll be happy together.
Forever.
Love you so much, Miller.
There's him again.
Look at the picture on the wall.
What picture?
Is it going to...
This one.
Right here.
Oh, okay.
Is that going to give us a secret?
Yeah.
Alright.
And like, look at it and then like look up.
Are you good?
I don't know.
What's wrong?
I wonder what happened.
Alright, I'm looking up.
Wait, it won't let me look up.
What do you mean?
with the right with the right analog it didn't let me what
it didn't let me look up the secret you missed the secret no
but i want to look at that too move i'm listening to do you
know french yeah we he says i don't have the tools to do it
do as i say and that's all i'm live translating fuck you i'm
live translating for you oh okay Nothing asshole Stop stop
it shut up junior.
You're sitting there and watching the prisoners Prisoners a
real is that is this a prison?
Do you not subtitles on?
You don't have subtitles on do you?
No, I do.
I have them on Why not get to see the subtitles at the
bottom?
Yeah, but what if you weren't looking at them?
I'm so traveling
I'm talking to the boyfriend.
Oh,
I'm telling him, I'm telling Alex about the ghost.
Like ghosts.
Oh, I'm going to listen.
The rest of the guys were just trying to scare me.
What the hell was actually on the map?
Oh, I was stuck.
I'm stuck, I can't get over there.
Hold on.
I see you.
I can't get over there.
How'd you get over there?
Hold on.
I'm coming.
LB, LB.
About this whole ship.
Yeah, I want to know what the fisherman is going to be
doing.
Yeah.
Oh, there you are.
and if they don't find any gold this whole situation what
the fuck happened what happened what happened Alex just
disappeared on my screen what did you do Alex we're doing
this is a fucking old ship but maybe it still has a radio
that works I doubt it find it bridge that's very hopeful
where the fuck is brad in all of this he's in the room
someone he's just existing okay well we're not gonna do
anything from here
okay in the end we gotta make sure julia survived there was
some stuff oh there is there's over here yeah there's oh
here there's one over here i'm steering what's this oh oh
you got it you got this yeah i know how to hold now i know i
found a bed
i did it i did it mint nice not oh what's this oh no i found
it the way out that's the game we're how am i oh there hey
wait what's this i wonder why it's abandoned there's a
newspaper oh secret found 1947 archaeologists missing in
iraq 24 british archaeologists have gone missing in the
mountains of iraq the hudson expedition arrived in the
kingdom in september last year with a starting goal
unearthing and then oh oh this must be the thing we found in
the cargo Yeah.
This could be the cargo thing.
That's why they're all possessed and...
Yeah.
They're cursed.
This is cursed.
Is there anything else we missed in here?
Oh, what's this?
Oh, my God, Bradley's scared me.
Oh, my God.
There he is.
Right there.
Oh, my God.
He scared me so bad.
He just doesn't do anything.
He's useless.
We know somebody that's not going to survive.
I can't get it open.
We can get it open.
We're not keeping Bradley alive, right?
We're not keeping...
Yeah, Bradley's gonna die.
Down with the nerd.
No nerds allowed.
Oh, uh...
This is the way out.
Yeah.
My excitement's going up.
All right.
I got this.
No, I got this.
yeah okay someone should create a distraction this is gonna
be loud okay Alex relationships oh Julia goes up oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh wait wait yeah you make a distraction
yeah why don't you do the distraction
um i'm gonna distract here i go i hope fliss doesn't die
Oh, maybe I shouldn't let you distract.
Hey, all that stuff she said, but double is gross.
And your mother's mother's too.
Whoa.
Don't talk about my mom.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm doing the quick time event.
Oh, thank God.
I'm doing a quick time event.
That's right.
Your mother's all sucking.
Run us out.
Yeah, your mother.
Yeah.
I dare.
Are they coming?
Why are you screaming?
Because they don't want them to hear us doing the vent.
We're already done.
Fliss, shut up.
Fliss, come on.
What do you mean?
You're Fliss.
I'm not...
Wait, what's going on?
Come on, Fliss.
Fliss.
Fliss, come on.
There you go.
Nice.
God, I can't believe she's not wearing shoes.
Where are you deciding?
Replace it.
Yeah.
They'll never know.
Oh, no.
Ah!
Where did it go?
We're venting.
Among us?
Oh, man.
We're going to get separated at some point.
I feel like it, too.
Find a way off the ship.
We need to keep going.
Come on.
There's got to be some stairs around here.
Okay.
Wait, why am I holding the light?
Wait, who am I?
Oh, wait, what do you mean?
Who are you?
You're always, wait.
Wait, are you Alex?
I'm Alex.
Are you Alex?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, now that we're...
Oh, wait, there's something over here, too.
There's stuff in here, yeah.
They're all leaving, but we got to...
Yeah.
We're splitting up already, guys.
I found a piece of paper.
It's good to know that we're splitting up already.
I found the guard duty regulations.
I found the uniforms.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, there we go.
Guys, nobody is allowed into 3A.
Okay, guys, I'm coming back.
Where are you?
No alcohol.
Where are you, Mint?
Hold on.
I'm right by the front door.
The door we just...
Here, look at me.
Turn around.
I'm turning around.
Where are you?
I'm right in front of you.
Oh, there.
Are we rinsed with that door?
There's nothing in there.
there.
I already went through that.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, man, I think we're going to get caught up by the
pirates.
No, why are you looking down like that?
Why are you always looking down?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm trying to look at where I'm standing.
I'm the one with the lights.
Oh, there's another door.
I have a flashlight, too.
How do you have a... Oh, wait, I found a map.
Why is the light flickering there?
Oh, it abounds.
What was that?
Okay, so cargo hole 2 is out of bounds.
Oh.
Yeah, do you, are you gonna remember Do you remember that?
Cargo hole 2 is out of bounds.
Yeah, when are we gonna get to cargo hole 2?
Wait, where do we go?
Why was the light flashing over here?
Yeah, you first.
You first.
What's going on in here?
What's going on?
We're already split up with this.
The lights actually work?
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, wait, I'm in the bathroom.
I'm in the bathroom.
Oh, I found the light in the bathroom.
Ladies first.
Alright.
It's reading time.
Dear Islas, I'm finally coming home.
This is it, darling.
One last trip across the Pacific, and I'll be back to you
and the girls.
I can't wait to see your faces.
Tell Ned and Nancy to get excited.
They're going to see Daddy real soon, and he's got gifts for
y'all.
I'm sure glad to be back at sea.
It's hotter than an Oklahoma summer out there on the land,
and there's no escape from it.
I've been all right because I got your letters to keep me
going.
They censored them, which is probably for their best.
Because sometimes the others steal them to read and I don't
like reading them reading our letters It really creeps me
out.
It keeps telling me there's a little boy on board and it
sounds like Ted what?
Oh, I wonder what happened wait.
Don't eat our feet are smelly our feet are smelly.
Oh, oh, we gotta go.
We gotta go We gotta finish the reading and but oh, we gotta
go.
We gotta go.
I think that's the side.
I think that's the side
I think I think Roro Roro Roro
I think the moment it starts getting smelly That's when
death is coming And we split up We split up with No no
they're right here They're right here Okay They're right in
front of me They're right in front of me I like how we're
the only ones with the flashlight And we're like back In the
very back Yeah Oh time to explore a lot of people who are
suspiciously nowhere to be found oh wait there's stuff here
yeah there's something here oh what's that what's that are
you picking it oh are you picking it up i think it's a skull
of a rat oh there's another thing here too it's a rat so my
chat was like i sure love how all the letters are like gosh
i'm happy to be alive wait what happened Oh my god What
happened?
I just got grabbed by a ghost hand What?
It was the loudest thing I've ever heard in my life Skipper
has caved out the boost for this goddamn trip Okay, none of
these lore Skipper How are you doing?
This lore is not interesting He's just talking about alcohol
Can I turn down the...
Is it the sound effects that is when the music...
It has to be the sound effects, right?
Or is it the music that goes ring?
I think I'm gonna... hold on Oh yeah Like, no, it's so bad.
I think it's the music.
It's going down to 35.
We got the 35.
That must have been some spooky music.
It was so loud.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how are you scared of ghosts?
You are a ghost.
I'm scared of jump scares.
Yeah, but it's just your neighbor grabbing your hand.
I don't know every...
Look at our feet.
Wait, oh, I could grab...
Wait, okay, I want to see what this jump scare is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do the rat.
I'll do the rat.
Oh.
Oh, I'm looking at it.
I'm watching.
Am I going crazy?
I might be going crazy.
There's nothing.
You lied to me.
There was nothing there.
What?
You're going crazy.
You didn't take your meds.
Yeah, I'm smelly feet.
It's not my fault.
Someone here was lying.
Oh, I found a picture frame.
I think this is a clue.
Is this a premonition?
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
What?
What is it?
What's the premonition?
You might want to look at that one.
Okay.
We gotta make sure nobody dies.
Yeah, I think...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Alright, we gotta make sure Alex doesn't die.
wait you're alex it's in your hands it's in your hands it
already warned you how to save alex i don't know what was
going on there oh they already told you bradley doesn't have
shoes either what's wrong with you guys mint has to protect
herself it's not my fault Dead, so that means I couldn't
protect myself from the beginning.
Oh my god, the flashlights.
Turn down the flashlights.
Turn it off!
Just turn it off.
Why are you putting your hand over a flashlight?
Oh, there's the pirates.
Save the battery, man.
Could be those charging flashlights, you know, the...
they're wearing ones are
we actually gonna get that yeah we gotta get that so we can
leave right oh no oh oh oh he's gonna break it he's gonna
destroy it so nobody can use it oh never mind what's he
doing he grabbed a weapon he has a hammer yeah um
I swear to God, if I have to play Fliss because of that, I
swear to God, man.
Say the fucking God.
Not the flare.
Well, she was the one who was like, I'm going to go get it.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, oh, you're calling back in.
Bradley's a hero now.
Brad, Brad, Brad!
All right, who's going to be Brad and who's going to be
Fliss?
Uh-oh.
All right, if I'm getting Brad, I'm making sure he dies just
so you know oh yeah if i get brad i'll do the same oh my god
um no i won't warn brad oh
my god we were very clear that we don't want brad anymore
brad has been voted off the island Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
Fliss!
He sounds really concerned.
Oh no!
Fliss!
Oh no, the other pirates are coming over.
This is such a long cutscene.
Oh my god, don't gasp like that.
Oh wait, it's the gun!
It's the guy with the gun!
Stop!
I don't want to see what's going on.
I don't cry.
You're a girl.
I want to know where are the others.
Oh By oh Brad, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Brad.
Who's gonna be doing it?
Oh no, oh my god All right.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, come on Brad.
What the hell?
That's not us.
It's the AI Yeah, it's the AI Wow, you guys come on Okay,
girl you're holding a whole ass lantern I think it's our, I
think, no, it's your fault.
You literally told Fliss to go down there and get the thing.
I mean, she should have, she was the one who brought it up
in the first place.
Right.
That's a very sick rat.
Oh, you're Fliss?
Am I Fliss?
Yes.
Uh-oh.
We're split up.
Wait, what are you?
Who are you?
I'm Alex.
Are you Alex?
Yeah.
are you getting are you oh no we're split up this is you are
they interrogating you no we're just we're just walking
we're walking somewhere okay all right we went i might we
might have these two die what are you sacrificing fliss so
that no i says both of us you're the one that go down fliss
they're fucking go down there i know she it was her idea she
said i'm gonna go down there and get it and i said okay do
it bet that's what i sent to her oh my god julie it looks
really scary she just looks like a she looks so scary just
standing there in the middle of the walkway yeah we like
fliss we don't want fliss to die you're the one that sent
fliss down you had a choice not to send fliss down there she
probably she wasn't gonna listen to me Let's be honest.
She wasn't going to let us go.
She was going to be like, I'm going down there.
We don't know that.
You gave her the choice.
Bliss wasn't telling you to do it.
No, she wasn't.
She said, I'm going to go get that.
And then my choice was tell her, don't or go get it.
And she made her choice.
She could have been like...
Yeah, but you said go get it.
You chose to go get it, didn't you?
I'm stuck.
Hold on.
Okay, everybody.
I'm stuck.
You guys, I'm stuck.
Oh!
There's a dead guy!
Uh-oh.
Oh, it was a...
It was just a hat, JK.
Oh.
I'm stuck.
I'm so stuck!
How do I get through here?
So, we have a very paranoid gunsman.
He's very scared.
Is he experiencing...
Oh, there we go.
is the experience no what's going on what's going on on your
side i'm fine everything's fine i have a hat now we have
yeah i got midon i got midon's hat what you got the man i
got the man hold on there's got to be stuff in there all
right there was screams
screams on my end man there's screams on my end you're cool
take your meds take your meds uh uh don't don't look it's
fine there's scary stuff over here i just saw some organs
okay chill calm down you saw organs yes they were organs
they were like live organs somehow they were live in the
wait what you found a secret oh i found i'm having beef cats
Oh, Christ.
No way.
Tuesday was cereal.
Home fried potatoes, boiled eggs.
I found a body.
Oh, I found a bone.
You're like, cereal.
Back on Jokey's side.
Here's a body.
that's not until that's not until fridays come on body is
not on the menu yet wait there's soup here you want to we
gotta keep moving and find austin oh now oh soup du jour i
found another secret oh my god julia there's no time for
messing around alex god oh no the stinky feed is here oh i
have feet too i just oh oh my god where are why did we split
up oh it's fine oh there's a child i think there's running
children again really okay you're really in trouble i
haven't seen anything yet i remember the last time there was
running children oh wait so i heard something what did i
hear i found a notebook it says what does it say uh nothing
i can't even open open the notebook idiot oh i just look oh
there we go oh okay it's a diary oh read it read that diary
june 18th wednesday we hadn't been at sea long and i'm sick
of the damn food already that muck we ate tonight was a joke
the cooks do their best with what we got i'm sure but man
i'd kill for something fresh first thing i'm doing when i at
home is having me a tall glass of milk.
June 19th, Thursday.
Everyone of the U.S.
papers was talking about that massacre in Philly.
Are these guys American?
All I'm seeing is while you're reading this diary, our
kidnapper fucking died.
I'm just like, listen, you read the diary and the kidnapper
disappeared.
me it's crazy to think how we're out here traveling the
world trying to keep our country safe there's people killing
each other in the streets back home i could show you the
beer after reading about the captain has issued a ban on
booze guess i'll be counting sheep tonight oh my god there's
more oh no oh my god there's more oh we found a secret who's
it was you you no oh wait i found yeah i found the secret
june 20th friday some of the guys had a little wrestling
company competition in one of the cargo holds today i did
okay but wagner eventually knocked me out of it i joked he
should be disqualified on account of his size but no dice
like how you're reading it i'm still i'm trying to find the
way out and you're just standing there reading to die it
didn't take a whole crowd of people to pin him down he
certainly ain't for sure june 21st saturday i'm sure the
cargo we have in the hold has something to do with the squad
that went missing their leader jones heard a legend about a
room full of ancient solid gold statues from a manchurian
child emperor they were said to be cursed but that sounds
like a load of baloney it's the child it's the child i hope
to god um that you're heading over to where i'm heading over
because I'm progressing right now.
I'm reading.
I'm progressing.
It's knowledge, okay?
I don't know if they found them, but they never did return
from their mission.
Maybe they're returning now.
Okay, that's all of it.
Cool.
Alright, cool.
I got away and, like, I'm back in the cargo hall.
Oh, I'm, like, far.
I don't know where I am.
Yeah, I could tell.
I could.
I could tell.
Oh, I got the knife.
I heard something, though.
I think I'm starting to hear people.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I see A premonition picture.
I'm getting a premonition.
I'm getting a premonition right now.
Mine was the one where, like, it was a guy in a hood with a
stick.
Oh my god, I just saw Bradley's death.
Wait, how does he die?
How does he
die?
Wait, I just picked up the knife.
No!
It's someone wearing a raincoat.
Why did you pick up the knife?
Yeah, he was the one that was holding the...
I didn't know!
I picked up the knife.
picked up the knife while you said that oh ah what just
happened Bradley what's going on I doomed him I worried I
picked up the knife I'm scared what is something's moving in
the shadows oh charles rats
my relationship with are you fixing my relationship with
julia went up but she she was a Oh my god, they split me and
Brad.
Brad and I got split off.
Wait, you split up?
You're by yourself now?
Yeah, I'm by myself.
The door closed on us.
Uh-oh.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm in the room with the dead bodies!
Uh-oh.
Which dead bodies?
The, the, the, the, the, the ones that were carried on the
ship at the beginning.
oh my god i'm going crazy brad brad like hello i'm seeing
hallucinations oh oh my god i'm with the bodies i'm with the
dead body oh i can look at that i can observe every single
body oh god i'm scared oh god i'm scared oh god i'm scared
oh we're both fucking up we're both fucking up man we're
supposed to see that secret we're both missing bodies in
here there's two bodies what the what's this practically
falling off anyway what does that mean bullet um is this
even human what is this what is going on i just want to
reunite with at least somebody i don't want to oh leave
leave hold on i'm not done yet i'm not done yet oh oh
there's zombies are you okay what's going on you found a
secret There's zombies!
I'm just looking at the bodies!
I don't...
I found another secret!
Save Brad, save Brad!
Save Brad!
Save him!
I got another secret.
Plus four for four!
What do you mean?
You're getting secrets!
I'm... Woo!
what do you mean oh my god there might be brad might be dead
oh no i'm in the ballroom i remember what happens on ghost
ship not the ballroom it's okay that was outside that was
outside wait it's not letting me do it inside the ballroom I
saw the movie no they were out on the deck they were out on
the deck in the ballroom wait the ballroom's on a deck uh oh
that might be stuck where are you where are you doing I'm
trying to do this I'm trying to do this but it's not letting
me my right stick is stuck I think press it I only have to
press I think I'm having a dokey bird problem You gotta wait
until I progress Keep holding the trigger I am, I am It
doesn't let me progress unless I hold the trigger Hmm Is it
the left one maybe?
No?
You're going through my problem now Yeah Good Wait, I don't
think it'll let me Wait, I don't think it'll actually let me
progress unless I do Oh wait, no, there's a room over here,
never mind Okay, let's go Okay, let's go Okay, sorry guys, I
tried I really did.
All right, let's see.
What did you have to do?
It was like, I'm trying to open up a curtain.
Oh my God.
Hold the stick I was.
I'll try one more time.
Oh, there's a pentagram book.
There's like a sorcery Satan book in the ballroom.
That's not good.
Guess we'll never know.
I read the spooky book.
Oh, you're cursing us.
I read the spooky book and there's blood here.
in the ballroom.
You were seeing a whole lot of bad stuff.
I haven't seen anything.
Like, that's on you.
You literally put me in this situation.
What do you mean?
I didn't do anything.
Oh, I'm in, like, a really bad area.
I feel like I'm... Oh, what the?
Oh, oh, there's a blood fountain.
Why do I get all the bad stuff?
I think I see a corpse.
Oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
There's literally a blood fountain here.
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, now they're real people!
Ah!
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Um, oh, what the?
I'm touching.
Where are you touching?
Where are you touching, Mitt?
I touched it.
You touched it?
You touched the bad thing?
Oh, and you're telling me not to touch the bad thing, but
you're touching the bad thing.
I was, I little, I just booped a guy.
Come on.
A dead body became alive.
Is that not bad enough?
I just went boop on his face.
Oh, I see another premonition.
Oh!
my god wait what just happened wait what somebody's drowning
on this one sure yeah i found the picture oh okay i think i
was too slow oh i turned on the lights the lights are on now
oh oh oh no oh it's the guy it's the guy with the hammer
he's after me oh wait i'm bradley bradley wait is he live
bradley's a I did it!
Why am I by myself?
That's right, I kept...
What?
I was following you.
He's like talking to me.
He's like, Fliss?
Hello?
Fliss?
Wait, where'd you go?
Oh!
I think I was following you.
Oh.
I think I've been...
I think I've been trouble.
Oh, there's a dead body!
Yeah, you were in trouble.
I left you there.
I'm gonna touch this guy I'm gonna touch this guy Don't,
don't, don't jump at me Don't jump, why am I taking the
bullet out of it?
You're definitely in trouble, I left you there Why'd you do
that?
Why'd you do that?
I'm trying to save you at the quick time events You said you
were gonna kill Oh shit!
I forgot!
I was scared!
I should have just left you!
No, you know what?
I kept him alive, so you had to play him.
I'm playing PT, actually.
Do you play?
I'm following you, but you have less clothes on.
Oh?
I think you're trying to seduce me.
What?
Oh!
I'm watching.
I'm following.
Wait, what happened?
Fliss!
Oh, oh.
She just disappeared.
Oh, she's back.
I think Fliss is a ghost.
yeah that's what i saw too you saw yourself you know you
were a ghost oh i'm looking at the bullet again oh this time
it says my name no it says alex on it is alex gonna get shot
i think so oh no oh fliss what does that mean do i open this
again nuke oh matura gold You found the gold.
I found the gold guys.
We're gonna be rich.
Don't be greedy.
Remember the hint.
I'm playing PT.
I'm playing PT real
Now you know how I felt when I was that's the guy with the
gun is here now This is this is why I kept Bradley alive
This is why I kept Brad alive now you have to deal with it
It has textures floating.
What is that?
What is going on on your end?
The game is glitching a little bit, I think.
Oh, the bullet turned into a slug and it's eating me.
Okay, okay.
Are you killing Bradley off right now?
Oh, we got slugs on us.
We got slugs on us.
Found a secret?
Oh, my God.
I'm exploring.
Gippy Kaiye.
Ooh, look at all these.
items look at all these items around me let me read some
more let me guys guys oh i'm stuck okay never mind oh look
at all this lore
okay read it out loud all right i got a book too oh my god
the stanford operating procedure for handling hazardous
chemicals oh are you ready for some science i put the down
this is my fourth time going through the same hallway
there's just blood on the ground and a bullet let's see it
says oh it says ha ha oh i just saw alex die wait what no
it's not really him oh okay okay that's good i guess because
we only wanted brad to die oh my god i fucked it up but take
it take it home brad you take brad's demo you had every
opportunity i was panicking oh oh that was a quick time
event my bad oh oh oh i might act he might actually die oh
wait did you actually kill him i was i was adjusting the
sound and i missed the quick time no he's fine he's okay
okay we can't die from a hallucination okay this is what
just happened I gotta go You guys No, we're in a different
hallway now We made it out I can't believe it You were given
one quick time I had to do like 20 During that entire ride
You and you get one quick time event And you messed it up I
was adjusting my sound Now it's just so loud It's fine Don't
worry about it We're just worried about your So, why are you
obsessed with what I'm doing on my end?
Oh, I feel like something's going to come out now.
Oh, oh, what's over here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, we don't even know where to go.
Oh, that's over here.
We don't know how to go.
I don't know either.
I'm just, I'm stuck.
Gosh, there's so much to do.
There's so many options.
This is really, this is really choose your own adventure.
Skeletons, skeletons.
It really is, because I don't know what to do.
right now patrol vehicle skeleton one okay oh there's the oh
this is here memorandum what you will ask to be kept
informed of the radio situation we attempted outgoing
messages of the following times with no response oh my god
i'm going crazy you found a secret but i'm going crazy
that's how intense everybody is i mean bradley's been pretty
crazy this whole time so like oh i found a wrench oh my god
take that take that back to the ballroom take that take that
yes oh that's the wrench i found that wrench earlier wait
next to the guy that was hanging yeah okay wait what next to
the guy that hung himself um he was there was no hung person
are you sure yeah i'm i'm pretty sure are you sure yeah oh
the tiniest a button i've ever seen in my entire life oh
wait what's going on oh there press a okay i'm gonna head
outside to the deck again and see if i can get out again oh
press oh i think i'm trying the door i'm gonna go outside
You're going outside?
Yeah, I'm going back outside.
I can go outside again!
I still haven't seen...
I'm outside!
The outside is real!
It's an old boat, Bradley.
Chill out.
Okay, I'm going downstairs.
Oh!
When you go outside, it makes you go back inside.
Oh, so he'll PTP.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm back here.
Here we go.
Oh, you cannot see the bottom.
Oh, boy.
Bradley, you're gonna die.
You're gonna die, Bradley.
What?
What's going on?
Oh, I think I'm fine, actually.
Oh.
Oh, you dropped a wrench.
No, don't drop the wrench.
We worked so hard for that.
What was the point of all of that?
Brad, is that you?
Oh, I'm seeing shadow people.
Uh-oh.
Brad, is that you?
No, wait.
Do you see me?
Oh, no!
That's the cutscene!
I could kill Brad right now!
Wait, no, don't!
That's me!
Ben, don't you!
Don't kill him!
I'm gonna kill him.
Brad, that's me!
You're as happy!
No, it's not you!
That's me!
Don't do it!
That's literally me!
Do not!
Wait, there's multiple!
There's like five stars.
Come up easier!
There's nothing!
There's jealousy!
Don't do anything!
I almost bashed your head and I'm serious.
God damn it!
Wait, who are you playing as, Fliss?
I think so.
Holy shit, you almost bashed my head.
I almost killed you.
I almost did.
It's because you begged for it.
Oh my god, the guy is right behind us.
Oh shit!
You like hovered over my head!
You're like, hmm, do I do this?
Wait, are you Alex right?
I think so.
Wait, I got pulled up.
What do you see in the water?
I don't know, I got pulled out now.
Oh, I saw a baby.
Or I'm in the plane.
Whoa!
oh he's a zombie there's a zombie oh kill the zombie I
punched him I punched him I think Julia's gonna drown wait
you're Julia yeah I know
I did everything I was supposed to do no I'm fine oh hello
you seem really calm okay I have to help you now.
Wait, there's multiple of you.
What just happened?
Wait, what's going on?
It's all just black.
What do you mean?
I clearly saved your life.
I can't say anything.
Oh, oh, this is a premonition.
What's going on?
Oh, who do I save?
Do I do it?
Wait, who do I save?
I'm heroic.
What do you mean, who do you save?
It's really my choice.
Do it!
Keep going!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
You made me kill a man!
You were already working on it!
I was making sure he'd, like, bait, not actually kill him.
Deal it.
You were the one.
You could have let go at any time.
Okay, I'm just kidding.
Man, you made me kill a person.
You could have stopped.
I don't have any control over you.
Yeah, you did the right thing.
See?
Oh, what the?
What the fuck?
How did he get thrown?
What?
What the fuck?
Told you there, Sommies!
What the?
What is going on?
Oh, oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh, my god.
Punch him!
Do something!
Oh, my god.
Run!
Let's go!
Are we doing anything?
Quick time event.
Who is he?
That's the guy that had the hammer, right?
That's the hammer guy?
Why does it look pruney?
He was in the water.
It's John Medan.
Oh, my God.
It's Medan.
It's the man of Medan.
Oh, my God.
Hey, stop.
Don't mess up your QTE.
You can't trip on the stairs.
Fuck.
Uh-oh.
Come on, Julia.
Hit it.
He's here.
You're gonna get you from the bus.
Uh-oh.
We killed daddy.
Oh.
I hope.
Oh my god.
You did it.
I'm so proud of you.
Holy shit.
I'm actually proud of you.
Wait, which way do we go?
Which way do we go?
I don't know.
Are you deciding?
Oh.
Jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump
jump jump jump jump jump Let's jump we're quick.
Oh, oh my bad.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh Maybe we shouldn't have jumped My backer keep going which
one which one
That's fine You're gonna kill a second man.
You're obsessed with it.
Oh Oh my god, I did help my hero!
Volk.
Oh my god, keep going.
Oh, we're outside.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm a hero!
You're killing him!
I'm blood firsty!
Oh, this is the scene.
I did!
We did it!
Yeah, you saved him!
Oh, oh my god.
It's flesh.
Yeah, it's me.
Come on.
Let's go.
Where's Bradley?
Oh, he's alive.
Everybody's alive.
We're doing it.
We're supposed to kill people, but somehow it's working.
Wait, if I was Bradley alive.
We're too good at the game, I think.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, keep going, keep going.
Murder works?
I think, yeah, I think we'll be all right here.
Well, okay.
Okay.
What?
Why do you think that?
Yeah, I don't know.
Bradley, you almost killed Fliss.
I think he's just a surprise that everybody's alive.
Okay.
wouldn't you say yeah yeah crazy i didn't see so many dead
people kind of disappointed in that why do you mean you
hadn't saw them come alive apparently have you figured out
what's going on what how to stop it how to save the lives of
your poor no do we just leave yeah we just leave i hope
although it seems the ship's previous occupants never
managed to of deaths that night the whole ship died right
yeah let me help you out oh i watch go ship oh boy another
hint okay yeah i would do two yeah i need some help yeah
give me a hint man i don't want spoilers well then how can i
put this there may be forces at play here that are more
scientific scientific even some that are more political, you
know, less supernatural.
What?
Perhaps you started to realize that.
Spatial expression.
Everything and everyone may not be quite what three, two,
five, two.
What the fuck does that mean?
Oh, they're all kings.
I hope that helps.
What does that mean?
What?
That doesn't help anything.
What your poor unfortunate some making of all this and how
you might avoid any more?
gas yeah it's all gas it's not back to it it's not
supernatural it's the gas we're hallucinating because of the
gases yeah the more we're inside the more we're getting
hallucinations gas gas gas i don't think we should go back
inside julia okay all right what the hell was wrong with you
back there i don't know mint you almost bashed my head
that's ridiculous What the fuck is going on with this ship?
We're seeing dead people.
I gotta be honest, it feels like there's some like, like
evil, like literal evil going on down there.
Let's just stay calm and relatively sane about this, okay?
The stuff I saw.
It's like there were these old soldiers, they were bodies,
they were dead, but then they came alive and that doesn't
sound that crazy right about now.
Alex wasn't the only Alex.
What are you talking about?
Yeah!
That's why I was confused.
That's like, what do you mean, Alex wasn't the only Alex?
Wait, what are you deciding?
I wouldn't hurt you.
I'd never hurt you.
You know that, right?
I'm truthful.
This can't all be happening.
Oh, relationship went up.
We're fixing it.
Oh, we're fixing it.
We're fixing your mess.
No, joy.
No, their prior mess.
They had a mess already.
We're just...
making it better you know what do we know that's real um um
is this a ghost ship am i crazy or are we on a ghost ship
like ghost ships are real and this is one and we're totally
on it and oh holy shit we're so totally fucked i was gonna
say the same thing yeah i'm not crazy people to see weird
shit here apparently the guards were super freaked out by
something they saw in the cargo holes oh that said a bunch
of guys go ship real because they were really freaking out
by something yeah oh oh there might be like bacteria on the
gold that's eating our brains it's a brain eating bacteria
anyone figure out what happened to all the sailors did they
catch a rescue boat or something oh i mean we've seen their
bodies yeah a shift so where'd all the corpses come from
they actually look like they've been scared to death a heart
attack i'm not gonna ask about the gold it keeps me like ask
about the goat i'm not gonna ask about the gold it's a curse
gold lately our head was like don't be greedy oh it's fine
oh I'll ask about the gold don't worry about you I'm
avoiding the gold I got you I got you don't worry I'm
supposed to be greedy!
I'm just wondering.
What's wrong with being curious?
Oh my god.
Did you grab that, though?
She grabbed it.
No, one of the captains grab it.
Oh.
If we can find it and use it.
Oh, it's working.
That's great.
Do you think it still works?
Yeah, but where's the radio?
It was blinking.
See?
I know that means the radio's on, but where's the radio
station?
Oh, we're there.
over there right yeah oh what the fuck yeah okay who am i oh
i'm fliss i'm fliss okay i'm alex okay before we start wait
i need to pause i need the bathroom i'll be right back okay
let's look at the collections and characters everybody i'm
fliss i'm innocent i'm relaxed oh oh all of our oh my god my
relationship with alex is insane i just watched it go all
the way down um brad is whatever Julia's pretty down.
Conrad, but I'm innocent.
I'm relaxed.
I'm excited.
I'm altruistic.
I'm guarded.
I'm motivated.
Oh my God.
What secrets?
Wow.
Oh, actually we haven't even found that many, have we?
What's this?
Flight plan.
Private Miller, Master Miller.
Our bearings.
What are these?
The kitchen knife.
Oh, these are the hints that we've gotten, I think.
Yeah, these are the hints.
our premonitions cut of your gib in the offing high and dry
master miller yeah master miller let's see what whoops gosh
I'm so used to playing japanese games where the circles to
press okay oh my gosh brian carter i'm back oh welcome back
all right what were you doing i was looking at our secrets
yeah did we get some good secrets oh yeah oh i'm surprised
we're making it this far all right i'm ready honestly okay
all right um anything else in here i don't think so i think
we're supposed to go outside the longer we stay inside the
more we inhale the gas you're right but we're outside it's
fine yeah that's why we got to stay totally effed oh my god
we're so effed right now why are you playing as fliss and
not my girlfriend julia oh yeah i don't know yeah i i looked
at our relationship uh fliss's relationship with alex is
completely down oh what what did you do what did you what
did you literally go bed like let's go down there i've never
been fliss i've been like let's go down there what's this no
what's this what i'm gonna get i'm gonna look at it i'm
looking at it i'm looking at it i'm looking at it too i'm
looking at it i'm looking at it oh oh there's bullet holes
there we can't we can't use that we can't use it we gotta go
forward oh yeah he did accuse her of being in cahoots that's
true yeah didn't you accuse me no i didn't do that you made
the choices oh we're finding a way up is that what we're
doing i went to find a way to get to the radio oh i thought
okay i thought we had to just get over there oh my gosh
we're acting really casual for like you know some for like
you know for almost for seeing several dead people and i
killed a man i killed several men i found a way out
i think this is our way up i mean it's the only way up give
me a look what give you yeah yeah you're a strong powerful
woman oh my god damn It shouldn't be me that gets the lift
up.
Are you right?
Holy shit.
Yeah.
And he doesn't even help her get all the way.
He just pulls you a little bit.
I was like, all right.
I did my job.
I'm a gentleman.
Dang, she's strong.
Oh, we're back.
Did no one help Brad?
No, there he is.
It's standing right there.
I know, I know.
But no one he helped him get out.
He just climbed up himself.
Brad, are you okay?
You help him.
Come here, Brad.
You're gonna talk to him?
Bro, we gotta find the radio tower!
We're in it!
The longer we're here, the more we're inhaling the gas!
He doesn't care!
Okay, he doesn't really...
He really doesn't care about me.
Okay, fine.
He doesn't care about you.
You literally almost bashed your head.
Well, he almost bashed my head.
If anything, I shouldn't be wanting to talk to him.
Okay, but we gotta split up.
We gotta split up.
Who's that down there?
Who's that?
There's someone down there.
So, but that's Brad.
Wait, there is.
Wait, you're right.
Who's that?
I'm going to see it.
I told you this way was the better way I told you I told
you.
Oh, oh Ladies first Ladies first.
I'm a gentleman.
All right.
I'll go here.
No, I can't see it's so dark Madame, Madame, why don't you.
It's so dark.
Oh, don't worry.
I'll flash.
I'm holding the flashlight in front of you now while you I'm
flashing your butt on the wall it's on the wall oh my god
what is going on here oh I don't like that camera you can't
see what's in front of us we can't see what's in front oh my
god oh it's gone it's gone it's gone yeah yeah yeah it's
gone oh it's Julia
it's Julia it's Julia
Why were you so afraid of your own girlfriend, huh?
No, I just wanted you to go first because I'm ladies first,
you know?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I guess I'll do it myself.
Yeah, do it yourself.
What was that?
Why were you screaming at my girlfriend?
I mean, it's Julie.
I thought we wanted to keep Julie.
alive.
Yeah, but I still don't like her.
Okay, we're trapped in there.
Okay, we're trapped in the toxic gas again.
Great thinking.
Alex, good job.
Oh, there's a guy in here.
There's a dead body.
Oh, this has to be the radio tower, right?
No, this is the captain's room, right?
Oh, this is the captain's room.
There's Brad.
Hi, Brad.
I'm looking for... Oh, premonition.
Premonition?
Yeah.
We need to know the premonition.
We need to know what's going on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
What is it?
It was one of the bad guys.
He just shoots himself.
Oh, what?
We have to convince him to shoot himself then.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm taking in these gases.
There's a door to our right.
Yeah, there's a door over here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Bradley, are you okay?
Why are you like...
I don't think Bradley's okay.
I feel like at any point I'm going to walk over and they're
going to be T-posing.
Can you open that door?
No, okay.
I guess we're going to go this way then.
Yeah.
all right here we go oh my god julia please julia what the
why are you so chill why are you just like standing there
like that i know she's chill like that she's so chill is
that another premonition no it's their route showed like
they went from california oh he went to the united states
and then korea and then whoa it's almost like they didn't
want anyone to know they were route in general yeah all the
way down there yeah there's two islands there oh i got a
secret we got a secret i found a note which i can record oh
i see you i'm watching you pick it up let's see the united
states department of the navy ship was blown off course uh
it was bad they couldn't establish a position oh there was a
storm well and somebody went overboard Someone failed their
quick time events that could have been you meant that could
have been me.
Yeah, oh, there's a dead guy here There's dead guys
everywhere.
Wait.
This is a radio.
Here.
I found it There's only one way I found it me this thing
actually still works.
I found it All right, let's see if you know how to do it you
found it you found it Oh
what am i listening for oh fucking you're the captain number
station military bandwidth which one are we trying to find
oh the military military probably right yeah come in please
do you read us over over that guy does that i don't think
yeah yeah at least there's someone listening uh the guy is
too panicked yeah that's what i was thinking too i'm gonna
say um i'm gonna say our coordinate hear me we're on board
an abandoned freighter well just like when it's 9-1-1 say
your address first one degrees 20 minutes west over over why
is he panicking yeah yeah i um mayday mayday thank you sir
uh we're on a large freighter say the address why are you
describing coordinates coordinates come in over come in come
in come in please anyone come in over oh you've screwed it
up oh no fliss you ruined it you're fliss no hey come here
look oh no brad wants to go down hey look at this bradley's
awfully brave, isn't he?
Just push him in.
Push him in.
It'll be so funny.
Yeah.
This one's got to lead somewhere.
No shit.
Anywhere will lead somewhere.
I think someone should wait here in case a message comes
true.
I'll go.
Obviously.
I can do this.
Whoa.
Brad.
You're a hero.
Let Brad go.
Sounds like you're scared of someone stepping out of your
shadow.
Brad, you almost killed somebody.
We should have left him to die.
Oh, what are you gonna do?
You're okay If you're sure you're up for it If he dies, he
dies If he dies, he dies Julia, what?
You know, my bodyguard I can take care of myself What?
Why are you going?
Fliss and Brad again?
Julia says she can handle it Oh, you're putting it Oh my god
You gotta let Julia and Brad One of us is playing Julian
Brad the other oh my god, don't say don't say that you're
gonna do it if you're not gonna do it
Don't don't say it I hope you get Julian Brad.
Oh my god, so loud.
I hope you get Julian Brad.
I hope you get Julian Brad
She's all scraped up.
Oh, no.
Everything still work?
Everyone okay?
Decide.
Are we okay?
We're okay.
Oh, God, you're the crazier one.
You're going to try and kill me at some point.
Now you'll know how I fell.
We're going to have to find the generator.
We can power up the radio.
Okay.
We'll wait here by the radio.
Finally, somebody's going to die now.
Someone will die.
Oh, thanks for the tiny lighter.
Just set you on fire.
Oh, whoa.
Let's go.
I feel like we should not light, put a lighter up with toxic
gas around us.
I know, right?
Like, it just doesn't feel like a very good idea.
Yeah.
Are you okay?
There you go.
Oh, we look like real like Scooby-Doo game.
Oh, was that the sick bay?
Is that what that said over there?
generator don't split up guys it's probably really nasty in
here oh that's where all that's where all the the dirtiest
of germs are wait this is where there's a door here yeah
yeah inhale the gases guys yeah i love going crazy more
hallucinations uh oh wait wait wait medical officers report
minutes of meeting between scientist x cwo walter bishop and
cwo told tom palmer with sergeant peter wood observing and x
for meeting with our team and says we can mutually oh my
thing talks about charles and joe it talks about like
charles beating up joe oh my thing talks about man chariot
wait wait wait wait oh this is actually really important
okay the united investigating the chemical and biological
agents in warfare.
Our act, limited by the Geneva Protocol, have experiments we
are unable to describe, or describes an investigation
during, to test the effects of human subjects on the
molecule crystal structure hallucinogens, codenamed
Manchurian Gold.
Oh my God, that is!
Unitions, battle.
It was even relatively minor, observed to trigger
significant hallucinations.
Men, highly convincing.
Some are seeing and hearing things that were not really
there.
Even the danger was manifold and in its intensity.
Okay, so it is toxic gas that we're inhaling right now.
What else was over here?
It was nothing.
It was just...
Lock me in jail, bad boy.
You have a boyfriend.
What the fuck?
I'm unhappy in my relationship.
I can tell I can tell you've been actively sabotaging it oh
this is the report oh this is where I was at yeah this is a
Charles the Charles and Joe beating up thing yeah this is
the thing I read and then there should be blood I can't
believe you tried an NTR with his brother that's fucked up
there's the blood that I saw earlier oh my gosh don't worry
about it the longer we stay here, the more toxic gas we're
gonna get.
Ooh!
Toxic gas.
Yummy.
I can't wait to see the kids.
How did you...
Whoa.
That's me.
I'm in the sick room.
Whoa.
Did you hear that?
Oh, that's a body!
That's a dead body I found!
That's him!
The little kid?
What?
Maybe this was somebody's son from on board.
Two pops.
Come back soon.
No, there's a dead body literally right next to me.
where i'm gonna go see it oh uh i don't see a body what
there's literally no body here wait what oh on the ground
yeah i'm looking at him what is this this is important i
observed signs of severe distress consistent with evidence
of panic observed in the same soldier during his watch dude
oh it's talking about the hallucination that he's been
getting yeah oh manchurian gold yeah this is the body yeah
this dead body yeah i didn't see him i thought he went in
the bed because that's where like sick bodies normally would
be yeah he was stuffed in the in this in this closet locker
and i like oh yeah yeah that that's why i was like him yeah
like a hundred years ago wait where did you go oh there you
are i was like where are we are we splitting up already yeah
we're splitting up we got to get that generator oh come on
oh i'm stuck wait hold on really we can go down we can go
down we can only go go down go down ladies first no you i
think bradley's the lady okay touche
yeah i found the ladder oh sure yeah what are you looking at
Is this the generator?
Gotta find the kitchen, Raggy.
Well, it sure looks gassy in here.
Roll.
I was broken off here.
Uh-oh.
I think I can just...
Wait.
Ow.
Are you okay?
Ooh.
Come down here.
Come down here, Julia.
She won't be able to get back up if you tell her to come
down.
Come down.
You have shoes.
I have bare feet.
I'm just a I'm a lady
Wait, I didn't see anything I just heard it Me too, I just
heard it too I was not paying attention I don't think there
was something there You're not Okay, so Follow my thinking
here Okay We know this ship was carrying the Minchuri in
gold Yeah That was really some sort of hallucinogenic bio
weapon Developed in China during World War II Right And we
know that it was super unstable Yeah.
Wait, but why am I?
Oh!
Oh my god, Brad, you're so smart!
It's not like we figured that out a long time ago.
He's the brainy nerd.
The officers thought it was just a bunch of jumpy GIs trying
to get out of guard duty.
This isn't a ghost ship, it's a floating bio weapon.
We might die because the military wants to keep it a secret.
Ooh.
Maybe there was a connection.
Maybe they made contact.
India and only Conrad survives.
Nobody here lives.
Because that's usually how it goes.
The military wants to keep it a secret.
So we're going to be like...
Well, we know those coordinates.
Yeah, they'll be like...
We'll be like, we're saved!
And then the military shoots us.
That's how it always goes.
Yep.
Oh, Netherlands.
Netherlands?
Oh, Rotterdam.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
God, this is not an American ship.
Not American at all.
It's not made in America.
They lied to us.
How dare they?
You go the other way.
You explore the other way.
No, I'm talking like, we're not splitting up.
Yeah, why not?
I can't believe we outsource this ship to Europeans.
That's why it's cursed.
I don't think there's anything over here except gas.
What are you trying to say about it?
to hap up the gas.
Hap up the gas!
My delusions!
Oh my god, anime girls!
We're gonna see the children!
It's this way, there's stuff here.
Okay.
I'm seeing anime girls!
Oh my god!
Remember to hop up the gas!
Hop up the gas!
Oh, what's this?
Wait, did we come this way?
No, we did.
We came from upstairs.
And it's working!
Oh, you're right.
yeah this is it all right just throw the switch and let's
get back upstairs how we go yeah how do we go back upstairs
boom okay let's get back upstairs there's got to be another
way up sure oh
we've lost power but we have it back can you hear me over
oh we need help now there are things on the ship that are
trying to hurt us over Recovery mission is unwrapped to your
location over.
Oh.
Oh, again.
Come on.
Work them in.
Okay.
Okay, well.
We have people coming to shoot us.
Yeah, we have people coming to shoot.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
There's a way over here, but there was also a other area all
the way on the other side.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Oh, gas.
Sweet, sweet, sweet, sweet, sweet.
My wife, who will?
She'll know the mine.
My god, this is how your waifus become 3D
No 3D, we won't Oh, there's a dead guy here Wait, where are
you?
I'm looking at a dead guy Where did you go?
He is not looking so hot Where the fuck did you go?
Did you go this way?
Oh, we definitely split up I split up I split up, dokey
Wait, what?
I brought you back
The fisherman must have bothered over from the Duke of
Milan.
You think it still works?
Wait, they were here?
Maybe a couple of minutes.
Should we bring it with us?
I mean, it's heavy.
I feel like we should.
Might as well.
Yeah, take it.
Yeah, why not?
Hell yeah, we should.
Half the boat is submerged.
Yeah.
The crows.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Just when we need to run.
Wait, we can hit him over the head with it.
You're right.
Is this where he's going to shoot himself?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh, he's dead.
He's totally lost it.
Yeah, he's crazy.
Oh, you see it?
Wow, imagine the smell in there.
What is he doing?
That's the guy Oh, there's the thing Yeah, for the boat What
is he trying to do?
Is he gonna cut him?
He's opening He's gonna open him up To see his secrets
There's gold inside him There's gold inside Open me up
There's gold inside Oh, he's hallucinating He's
hallucinating again You could totally like scare him Just be
like Oh Just be like I see you.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare fuck this up.
Don't you dare Okay Okay We died you messed this up.
There's a lot of pressure here though.
There's a lot of the stress makes it makes you focus more
There you go.
See it.
Told you You failed?
Why did I get it?
It sounds like you failed.
Avoid Olsen.
Uh-oh.
What are we supposed to do?
It's a sub kit.
I don't know.
I have time to read notes, right?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
There's mucho texto.
Wait, what?
Human bodies that have undergone mistreatment.
I don't think we have time to read!
Okay, I'm coming.
What's going on?
Oh.
Oh, oh, God.
Oh, God.
Hide.
Oh.
We've got a split.
He's holding something.
I'm just going to check it real quick.
There's nothing in there.
I swear to God.
That one's just scary.
Now we're gonna die.
No.
Yeah.
Nah.
This guy can only, you know, he can only hallucinate and...
There must be plenty of that to go around.
He'll hallucinate us, killing us.
It's fine.
Where were we gonna go anyway?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh And I'm to be left here to die But I am Oh Mitt Mitt Mitt
I'm giving you the pressure I knew I should have given you
the pressure If I can't give you pressure Would've been okay
It was not only It was just kill him It was just kill him It
was all the pressure The moment I stopped giving you
pressure See it?
It's fine!
Just keep going!
Just keep...
Bradley, please.
The doors are rusted.
Come on, we gotta keep going.
This is where he tries to shoot.
We have to convince him to shoot himself.
Yeah, this is the guy that I saw shoot himself.
Turn around.
Then we'll get a guy and it'll be fine.
Yeah, real slow.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, or why is he here?
None of that.
How did he get here?
Raise your hands up.
Slow.
Yeah, why is he here?
Why did he, how did he get here?
How did he get here?
Not like that.
What do you mean, none?
I said no changing.
Oh.
Mint, I swear to God, Mint.
I saw you.
I'm, I'm nice.
You really got to start!
We just want to get out of here.
I'm sorry, but if you're breathing, then you don't get much
of a choice in the matter.
You don't got to say.
What?
What do you mean?
Oh.
Oh, he's seeing him.
He's seeing him.
Oh, the gash.
What's changing?
The gash.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, what's happening?
Stay back for the miss.
Oh, there's a man!
There's a man!
Don't breathe the mist.
The mist, the mist.
Oh, I'm gonna say nothing.
Really?
I'm gonna say nothing.
You coward, you coward.
Inside with us now.
Please just come.
Why did you see some?
Why did I make the decision?
It's in one of us.
We have to convince this on him.
It's in him.
I went to say it's in him.
Oh yeah, I'll say I haven't breathed.
I haven't breathed any weird mist.
promise.
My deceitful went up.
Oh, me too.
I'm gonna say no.
You breathe.
Yeah, Bradley, you breathe it.
No, he's gonna shoot Brad.
Shoot Brad, shoot Brad.
There is no.
There was something back.
Oh, where do I go?
There is no mist.
There was something back there.
Oh, I think he's gonna shoot Brad.
I thought that.
Uh-oh, he's gonna shoot Brad.
Oh, you just came.
Oh, I missed him!
I moved him.
we want it say no we held our breath no look we held our
breath we did not breathe any of that stuff I fucked up I
fucked up Brad's gonna die I fucked up I fucked up we've
been down here for hours you've been holding your breath
this whole time it's true you're holding your breath right
now oh oh Uh-oh Oh, we did it!
I did it!
We did it!
How do...
He's gonna shoot...
What if he shoots us first?
He's gently!
Okay.
Come on, man.
Come on, shoot yourself!
The mist!
Persona!
What do we do?
You decide!
Stop!
Stop lying!
You can all see it, didn't you, Kansu?
I'm so...
Did you say...
Come on, come on!
I didn't say anything!
Why are you making him stall?
Oh, oh, oh!
You think we're alive!
Dude, just can't stop monologuing.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, maybe, maybe?
Persona?
Hey, man.
Come on.
Just quit.
Oh!
Oh, fucking shit.
Oh, we did it!
Let's go.
We killed another man.
Yeah, we killed another man.
Murder is the option.
Yeah.
Wait, why don't you keep the gun?
Is it empty?
Someone was like, you could have saved him.
Wait, we're supposed to save him?
Oh.
No, it was our premonition.
It was our premonition.
I thought we were supposed to kill him.
That was our mission.
Oh, I'm bliss.
Oh, it's 4.44 a.m.
Oh, my God.
It's so spooky.
Yeah, they took us hostage.
Why are we supposed to sit?
He's the bad guy.
Doesn't sound like my problem.
There might be some more gear down there we can use.
Murderers of my dad.
We were the murderers all along.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're they're going down.
Okay Why we see why we're saving the kidnappers?
Oh, oh my god.
I swear to God.
I don't think I'm no, I'm fliss.
I'm fliss.
Okay I'm doing this dead.
Yeah Okay, are you doing it right now?
Yes, I am.
Mess up.
Hey, I I had a good track record with this.
It's on you.
How do you mess this up?
There's too much pressure.
The moment I give you pressure, you do better.
I don't understand how that works with you.
When I stress you out, you do if you actually pass this.
Oh, my God.
There's a man down there.
The man of a den.
The murderers of a den.
Why?
Let's go.
Why can't I walk fast?
I don't know.
Come on, move, Liz.
Oh, move.
Move you I'm trying.
She's so slow Every time I pass it says mint failed it even
though you don't even do it Even the game says you failed it
It calls me oh, oh, you disappeared.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm heading over.
I'm slowly heading over here
Oh my god, oh Oh, oh, he's coming over.
Does it matter?
We need that distributor cap.
Stop talking.
Stop.
He's so loud, Alex.
I know.
He's like, hey, it's over here.
Hey, it's here.
This is not the way that we win.
Where?
How are they going to find us?
Oh, oh, is that your hand?
I don't know.
I sure hope so, me too.
I hope so, too.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, I don't think I...
How's there still more?
Who's that?
Oh.
Oh, he sees us.
What?
Jump.
Are we actually going to do it?
This is a lot deeper than I expected.
Yeah, it's pretty...
Get ready for the quick time.
What's the first one?
Men, please.
Oh wait!
I don't think I had to do it!
The gases!
Oh no, the gases!
The gases are like really...
He dropped the hammer!
Wait, what is...
What is it zooming on?
The hammer!
Yeah.
We'll get it.
We'll grab that.
I swear, do not use the hammer against me.
Oh, is he getting a heart attack?
Oh, he's gonna get scared to death now!
He's getting scared to death now!
We have to do this...
I think we have to do this fast.
But we're going to get hard.
Okay, this is the moment.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I have to make sure I don't get a heart attack.
I chickened out.
Are you fucking all right?
I got to make sure I don't get a heart attack, I guess.
Oh, I'm outside.
I'm breathing that pressure.
I can't believe it.
This is actual bullshit.
I'm fucking going as fast.
i can i'm going too i'm pressing lb lb is this it here oh i
can't see anything oh my god i'm going to the door it's fine
wait what's who's that what's that down there oh my god i'm
coming hold on I think those are bodies wait that's a guy
right there oh of course but they will shrink your movement
the taste indicate that in five of our cartoons have gone
missing what i'm coming i'm coming hold on there's a lot of
stuff in here there's a lot of stuff in here hold on i'm
trying to figure it out where he is he's dead he's dead it's
fine oh no immunity oh no the rats water purification
there's rats eating the dead body why did you get to go
outside He's kind of nice.
Oh my god.
I saw a dead body.
He was just chilling, though.
Manifest of personal effects.
Oh, no.
The dog died.
Oh, these are the guys that died.
Oh.
Oops.
Get off.
Get off, Rat.
I'm finding...
Hold on.
There's like three notes in here.
Get off!
Oh, my god.
I didn't get to read it.
Uh-oh, what's going on?
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Why do I have to deal with all of this?
There's rats here!
Wait, I just heard something.
Oh my god, there's so many rats.
I'm freaking out!
I'm freaking out over the rats!
Oh, I see you freaking out over the rats!
Chill out!
What the hell?
What the fuck was that?
You have to see that?
What's going on?
Do I...
Um, decide well, I guess.
What?
Who?
Who are you?
That's me, that's me, that's me!
Don't do anything, that's me!
Yeah, it's me, idiot!
It's me!
Is that you?
That's me!
Don't do anything!
It's me!
Uh-oh, I think Felice might die.
You are the one who's gonna kill.
The game is bugging out, man.
What?
I'm dying?
Why are you dying?
What's going on?
The rats!
There are no rats!
Don't kill me!
Don't you dare!
Don't you dare, mid!
Come on, Alex, I'm gonna put you out of your misery, Alex.
Don't kill me!
I'm gonna put you out of your misery!
Alex, I'm gonna put you out of your misery!
Don't do anything to me!
Stop!
There were no rats the whole time!
Oh my god, the game is fucking out right now.
It's always you that's about to kill me.
I swear to God.
I know you were the one who was the knife.
I didn't mean I didn't do anything with the knife.
You were a monster on my screen.
You were a monster.
What are you talking about?
You had two heads!
Well, you looked like you were getting eaten by brass, but
you weren't actually.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck did he come from?
Why are you there?
Wait, Brad?
No way.
Did we survive everybody?
Did we save everybody?
Did we... Did we...
Did we...
Oh my god, did we...
What the fuck?
No way.
No fucking way.
There's no way We saved everybody Oh my god Alright Let's
try it Even Even Conrad That's such a Crazy Holy shit Are we
just gonna forget that everything We're just gonna leave
this ship and just forget Anything ever happened?
What about Conrad?
I thought Conrad was gonna come back for us I know, I
thought so, too.
That's fucking faster.
He just dipped.
Oh, my God.
No way, that actually worked.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
There's Conrad.
No, wait, he came back.
He came back.
He has a gun.
Wait.
No, wait.
He's going to get on the ship.
Doki, wait.
No, he's going to get on the ship.
No, he doesn't know.
He killed Conrad.
No, they're going to kill Conrad in the end.
Oh no, God, don't go, God, don't go, don't go back, where's
the rest of the coastal car?
Where is it?
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh, oh, it's inviting
him in.
Yeah, oh, oh, oh, there he goes, oh, no, there he goes in.
Oh no!
Conrad!
Don't be greedy.
Do we get a choice?
Conrad, no!
Don't be greedy.
No.
Just let him die.
No way.
We saved him just for him to go back to the ship.
He has his AirPods on!
Where is the Coast Guard?
Yeah!
How did he get in here?
Oh my god.
The sequel is Man of Conrad.
Yeah.
I just don't know what happened to my brother.
He was trying to help us to get help, but he doesn't know.
Oh, it's like the until dawn ending.
Yeah.
Or they do the interviews and stuff.
God, we should have never split up.
Oh.
That's just her being sad about Conrad.
That's it.
We don't know if he's dead or not.
He's just, he's just chilling.
That's the end!
Oh my god!
No way!
No fucking way!
We're like, where's Conrad?
Technically we saved everybody.
No way, that's the ending.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's he gonna say?
He's just gonna stare at us?
Come on, say...
We make good choices.
Yeah!
That's really impressive for us.
Yeah, well, that really is.
I can't believe it.
We were not trying to save people.
It's all about decisions, isn't it?
Decisions made in a hurry, in a panic, made with the heart
instead of the head, or vice versa.
Sometimes those decisions take a long time.
Truly gone, Rad.
But there are repercussions.
There are.
Yeah, Conrad's dead now.
We don't know that.
There's no proof.
I think so.
I think he's dead.
Did we get the good ending?
The boat literally invited him in.
Maybe in little hope.
Maybe somewhere else.
Whoa.
But be certain.
We will meet again.
Whoa.
Inevitable.
Apparently, there's a DLC.
I don't know if that guy was just baiting us.
What the fuck?
I'm skipping.
Are we skipping?
Yeah, skip to the end.
There's DLC, for real?
Is there really a DLC?
Oh, that was a joke.
Okay.
Oh, are they vibrating for you?
Are they vibrating for you?
Are we getting a heart attack?
Well, they're vibrating.
You're vibrating.
Whoa.
What's going on?
Is it because of the beer?
Is it the beer?
The decompression.
Is this the decompression?
Oh my god, it's a beer!
I'm shaking a lot.
Shit, shit.
This is decompression sickness.
We can- I swear to God!
You can't believe it!
Oh my god!
We almost saved everybody!
He said congratulations, we went through the credits!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
Doki, it was beer o'clock, please!
It was beer o'clock!
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking beer o'clock!
clock.
We almost had a perfect run.
Like, fucking Peter, Jake, beer.
I can't.
Oh, my God.
But, can you have to understand?
Yeah, it was after the credit, so it doesn't count, guys.
It doesn't count, guys.
What happens after the credits is not our fault.
Oh my god.
I can't believe in the...
Oh my god, she died for Peter O'Clock.
After everything we've been through, bureau clock got us oh
my god holy shit you know i'm surprised like everybody lived
that was actually i'm surprised too oh my god that's right
we're special no other vtuber plays the game like us we we
stumbled our way into victory you can guarantee an original
experience here on our channel beers of my dad I can't
believe beer old clock you fucking kidding me I can't
why did the decompression take so long he said it was like a
couple hours or maybe a couple minutes Michael how did he
die how did she died now oh my god that was good that was
good that was good that was fun that was really fun we
should do the sequel to this next time is the sequel the
same where we have to play two different characters i think
so yeah yeah i heard little hopes not as good though oh yeah
i think all of these are all kind of like kuso games yeah
yeah it's not the it's not the game you guys it's who plays
the game the game guys oh my god at least hey nobody died
okay anything that happens after the credits is not like our
fault yes yes anything that happens is not our fault yeah it
might not be bero clock it could have been something cheap
else no one important died that's true that's true Like,
guys, Conrad's alive.
Alex, you know?
Is Conrad alive?
Yeah, Conrad's alive, guys.
Conrad's alive.
Like, how some of those, like, you were supposed to save
that one kidnapper.
But, like, he kidnapped us.
Why?
He kidnapped us.
He's a pirate.
Yeah, self-defense.
Yeah, it was either us or him.
Yeah.
Oh, someone's like, someone was like, it's a hallucination.
She's alive.
She's still on the trip or the ship.
She's like, Conrad, I waited for you.
So it was like time of death, Bureau Claw.
Oh my God.
I didn't think that that would be.
You didn't think actions had consequences.
After the doctor boyfriend was like, maybe you shouldn't
drink the beer.
so people are saying don't do little hope that it's actually
bad oh is it actually bad wait how many how many games are
in the anthology anyway house of ashes is house of ashes
good conrad survived up to the credits therefore it doesn't
matter so true so true i went very hard on those quick time
events i went
house of ashes is good oh okay house of ashes next yeah i
mean that was really fun that was that was are we say how
bad are we saying though like what in what way is it bad
because like i mean like bad as in like the story bad or is
it like the is it like buggy bad like if it's buggy bad and
then maybe not but if it's story bad we can make it work i
thought this one was great it was yeah this one was good
yeah This one was pretty good.
The story is terrible.
Oh, okay.
Then that's perfect for us.
Yeah.
It's like, fucking, I was trying to be a mercier, and then
Min here was reading a diary in a British accent.
Well, when we watch somebody, like, get killed on screen.
It's like, dear diary.
And then my uncle's like, ah.
you know whatever yeah we'll fix it we can fix the story um
don't worry and if the story is boring we'll just make a
podcast open the swift end the game guys it's not who it's
not the game it's who plays it exactly that a great time we
gotta continue the the trilogy yeah we got the anthology was
it the dark picture yeah we have to continue the dark
pictures anthology
Oh, gosh.
Well, thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks, man.
I can't believe everybody lived other than beer clock.
I can't believe it.
It's just half stupid way.
Like, I thought maybe she would die on the ship.
Like, you're like, oh my God, it's kicking in and whatever.
Yeah.
But no, she's just what decision you made.
She just collapses on the boat.
She died of cringe.
oh my god it just came out of nowhere too we were just like
yay we did it also we weren't intentionally trying to save
them we were just it just we just stumbled upon it like we
just we just like tripped and fell into saving everybody
somehow yeah somehow i mean we did all the cute well i
failed the one qte and the heartbeat one we still live one
whatever the one important one the important the one at the
end okay I see we're rewriting history right now yeah yeah
yeah the one I see I see you're not even paying attention to
beer o'clock the most important beer o'clock wouldn't have
happened if I don't know you exploded the the grill I
literally just don't do it do not drink the beer it was it
was just beer o'clock the doctor boyfriend was being like
that's a bad idea it was fine it was fine we didn't care
about Julia anyway Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, she was pretty much a Karen, to be fair.
She was.
Yeah, so it's like, you know, nothing.
You know, he told Alex could have got, Alex could have got
so much better, you know.
You know, and then Alex.
Yeah, we saved him from marriage.
Now Alex is going to fall in love with Flix or Flix.
Yeah, Flix.
Flix.
Yeah.
Flix, yeah.
Flix is so much better.
Yeah, Flix almost got together with Conrad.
Oh, my God.
They were making out.
Yeah.
yeah and then we we saved them we got we got bliss for alex
now she's a strong woman conrad just literally like front of
the boat like yeah where was the coast guard like he just
went there by himself i don't know he was clearly not
driving the boat like no yeah so it makes us why is he
dealing with this i was like where did where did the coast
guard go i also how did he get the
get the coordinates well we gave the coordinates over the
over the radio but how did he know to go with like how yeah
but then like the thing is he they were not they were on the
military boat they weren't on the exactly everybody else was
also on the military boat yeah so like i'm so confused why
was there nobody behind it
oh my god it's all right everybody lived everything that
happens after credits was hallucinations someone said if you
don't get the distributor cap you get rescued by the Coast
Guard oh so you picked up the the cap you told us you told
me to pick up the cap
okay but like if we if we picked up the cap like then like
would would kill conrad would conrad be on the boat conrad
would conrad be on the boat and see them and then the boat
and then be like oh my god we're rescuing rescuing you guys
okay i think you're getting gaslit i think i think we were
supposed to get i think we were supposed to supposed to pick
it up i don't know i think we were supposed to pick it up
i'm pretty sure no because we called the coast guard they
were coming they were on their way this cannot be on
not wait so so like if if we didn't pick up the distributor
cap we would have seen conrad on the boat and it would be
like i think so yeah they were out of the way someone said
not picking up gives you the better ending how do i not pick
it up do i just like not do it like how do i not pick up the
cap oh they would have ran into each other guys i gave you
guys a different i give you guys a cooler ending okay yeah
the cool ending we got was so great yeah our ending we got
was so much better yeah it's actually so much better like do
you guys really want to get rescued by conrad come on so it
was like you got the better ending now the world is
protected by from conrad's frizz we we took out both of the
We got two for one special.
Great.
Anyway, thank you, Doki.
Yeah, that was a good time.
GGs, Mint.
We'll come back for the next, what was it, Little Hope or
House of...
Whatever one we decide to play, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, we'll come back to it at GGs.
All right, we're going to talk to our chats now.
Yeah.
All right, see you, Mint.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my God.
I'm Peter Oak-Lock.
You can't be sad about losing Conrad.
It's fucking Conrad.
Don't lie to me.
You guys are not actually sad about losing Conrad.
Don't.
I know you guys don't actually care about him.
You guys were like, no, Doki.
Why did you save Conrad?
No.
Don't pretend you cared about Conrad this entire time.
I know that's not true.
I'm trying to find our chat overlay right now.
There it is.
Yeah.
It's y'all.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Y'all.
Oh my god.
I'm annoying for singing, man.
That was fun, though.
I had a lot of fun.
Let's see.
They gave us super chat.
Thank you.
Why didn't anyone use the boat radio to contact the Coast
Guard and tell them that they're okay now?
They gave the super chat because the radio died.
Oh, that was really, really, really fun.
I definitely had a great time.
playing with uh mint today um i'm glad we chose madame madon
it was one of the games that we were never able to actually
play in the past so we were like oh my god let's play it
let's actually play this game now that we can i'm glad we
did i'm glad we did um it was i never i didn't expect how it
was gonna go and so like everything was such a surprise like
the decisions that we made thank you the super chat thank
you thank you that was a super fun collab thank you so much
for the stream dokey thank you the super chat thank you
thank you yeah i had so much fun oh i wish i could talk to
you guys more but my throat is dying right now so i'm gonna
have to call it here everybody um but like i said it was
incredibly fun i had a great time with mint and i had a
great time with you guys dragons and also the the wisp as
well so i'm gonna call it here everybody um so my voice can
relax a little bit but as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye i need to find the ending stream bye